[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Game six of an epic World Chess
Championship match in London the
Challenger Fabiano Khurana
completely outplayed world champion
Magnus Carlsen with the black pieces but
heroic defense by the champ and a missed
opportunity by the contender continued
the trend of tension-filled draws now
with the first half of the match
concluded the two best players on the
planet are back to see who will land the
first punch game 7 action live from
London coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Championship coverage of Carl Semak
arowana as we see the first moves being
played in round 7 of what is so far have
been such a tight World Championship
match so many perfect play so many
incisive end games but right now we're
deadlocked the reigning champ Magnus
Carlsen with three points and the
American challenger hailing from st.
Louis we are we are recording this show
right now
Fabiano Tirana the first American to
challenge for the undisputed crown since
Bobby Fischer I'm Jennifer Shehadeh and
I'm here with grandmaster yasser sarah
wan to bring you a game 7 action and Wow
yeah it's what a week it's been so far
absolutely Jennifer pleasure is always
to be with you I'm still recovering from
that game 6 and as Fabiana said an
accidental victory there was this
amazing opportunity to win the game
checkmate in 30 was announced by the
supercomputer but just at the time that
we thought it was a draw this match has
brought us everything except the victory
jet this is the first time that the
players will have two back-to-back
White's so Magnus Carlsen has white in
game 6 will be white in game 7 and it's
underway that's right he is white in
this game and he tried everything with
white in those first few White's d4c for
today his choice was deep war but we'll
get back to that in a minute let's take
a look at the world championship format
for those of you who are just joining us
on this lovely Sunday well it's best of
1200 minutes for the first 40 moves you
see we have this luxurious three-part
time control and we have a price meant
of over a million euros but of course
the title is really the thing isn't it
if that's what it's all about become
with a world champion and our schedule
our schedule word round seven out of a
potential 12 plus tire breaks and we see
Carlson with the white today he was also
white in Game six
Fabiano Khurana though will end the
match with the white pieces assuming
they go the full 12 games and right now
that looks pretty darn likely it sure
does and of course you will be playing
on Thanksgiving Day yes mark your
calendars turkey and chess and now we
have Grand Master Maurice Ashley for an
update from the Women's World
Championship as well as a fun fact about
the title match between Bobby and Maggie
yes well we are now down to two that is
two players on the women's side as well
as after 64 players showed up and
amazing rounds five rounds of total
action we have gotten down to these two
players jus in June defeating that is
reigning champ jus engine defeating
former champ
Alexander Castilla to get into the
finals and Maria Musa Chuuk finally had
to bow out she is a former champion as
well as Katarina lag no showed her stuff
and was able to defeat her in the
tiebreak so now we have two absolutely
worthy finalists let's start with the
reigning champ herself
Grand Master Zhu engine look at how
efficient she's been throughout the
entire competition she needed the
minimal two games in every match to
knock out every single player ten games
total played she's rested every single
off day that is tiebreak day just
incredible performances cruising right
now but she will have to go against
Katarina like know who has had a
different path to the finals as Katarina
had an easy round in the first one at
least went to O then needed a tie-break
in the round of 32 but against pas
Giannina nine games in order to close
out that match including the Armageddon
game that she had to win with the white
pieces and also check out the round of
four against Maria Musa took where she
also needed a tie-break she's played
more than double
the number of games of her opponent will
she be fatigued as they have this
absolute epic match up the schedule
today rest day but the finals will begin
November 19th four games in a row to
decide the champion absolutely great
match of these two great ladies now to
Magnus and Fabi these two have battled
now in 2018 and 11 games 1-0 with 10
draws draws are quite likely folks these
two are the best players on the planet
after all
I think Magnus would throw away his win
if he could get one today as it will be
very exciting his second white in a row
will Fabi be able to block him so far
black has indeed have been okay we'll
take it out as the game has begun
Thank You Maurice and that Women's World
Championship they had their first free
day for everybody I think today they'll
be picking up Game one in there for game
match in this finals tomorrow alright a
repeat should we just jump right into
the game yeah yeah okay a repeat of yeah
where Magnus is white opened with one d4
and the players quickly got to this
Queens gambit declined position after
this move Bishop e7 now historically the
most favored move and by far has been
the move Bishop c1 to g5 but Bishop c1
to f4 is considered a very worthy
alternative and back in the 1970s in the
World Championship matches between
Viktor Korchnoi and Anatoly Karpov there
was a number of games played in that
match with this line of play now in
their first outing with this scheme
between fabbi and Magnus have you got a
very good position
Yeah right
and you were saying that 92 days
would be very testing but instead he
played the more tepid Bishop e2 right
Bobby actually got a good game right
there was rook d1 rook b8 and here we
all expected Magnus to play 92 Magnus
played Bishop e2 and after 94 that be
made a very very very comfortable draw
draw + drop love okay so this time
without night without rook d1 at the
immediate Knight d2 we understand this
move this move the knight first of all
there's this awkward pin so it stops the
threat of Knight e4 by breaking the pen
point number two this night on d2 is
actually threatening going to be three
where it will for Queen and Bishop so
it's a 241 kind of move you threaten to
fork the Queen and Bishop as well as
breaking the pen now as far as I'm aware
Bishop e7 getting out of that Knight b3
attack is the most common move now one
of the things that we've been seeing in
this match is that it's black who is big
dictating but that's a play Queen d8
instead I think you might have used
because you thought like you thought
they could maybe that it wasn't Queen
moving back to da but it was like the
move before but no 5 he's already played
Queen d8 after Knight d2 second if you
look in your live board on the laughs
game ok so he went Queen a 5 and then 90
to 92 now no indeed
and now Queen d8 was played Queen d8 yes
sorry I misspoke whoa
so how bizarre is that so from this
position you play Queen a5 you develop
your queen and on your very next turn
you you you retreat the Queen don't
worry guys I can guarantee you're not
gonna see night a3 Queen a five-night
might be too greedy 8 wow I'm still I
still trying to understand exactly what
that would mean okay so is white getting
the move Knight
d - for free it's not like it's a great
move because black does have ideas of
e6000 as was played in those World
Championship matches I I'm a good point
yeah so maybe we'll see you like native
3 Queen a 5 and then rook d1 reverting
to the other thing it's definitely
possible okay and I remember Gregory
kite Donna's very very aggressive
approach of castling long I like this
for 5e the idea here is to try to take
advantage of this pit of the potential
for a pin what do I mean well imagine
black plays a move like d5 d4 and here
we see the potential for a pin along the
D file you can't take the knight without
at least it costing you of the Queen so
I'm wondering boy I don't know all the
nuances of this system but I'm wondering
about castles the other point is again
as played in those World Championship
matches if you play move like 'if I've
Bishop to g5 d4 then quite often the
squares d5 and E for become very very
nice outposts for whites cavalry as we
can see in this situation so I'm
wondering about the move castles of
course black does not have to play
either of i-44 you could play a
developing move like rook e8 keeping all
of his options and asking white are you
really happy about castling queenside
but this is a key moment now after this
move whether he's gonna revert to
something like Knight f3 and then switch
back to rook e1 or whether he's gonna go
for the ultra sharp castles I say I
predict he's not gonna queenside castle
okay
well remember when he played Bishop e2
in that game - and he really didn't
achieve it and that's it now it begs the
question d4
like that's why I feel like your your
point is so compelling that but if these
Queens high castles tries to
contestant before as shown in your line
as does Knight f3 but right but that's a
question also if Knight f3
we simply transposed to a position we
had previously right right but you're
saying like but any other move besides
Bishop b2 or Queens high castles like D
for looks good right right it should be
to d4 maybe worked you on right away
yeah rook t1 is the is the final all
yeah if so the idea behind rook d1 is
that you wanted to play Bishop e2 bring
your king to the Kings side but okay
rook d1 that's taking some time and it's
still not a hundred percent clear in my
opinion that black shouldn't be
attacking in the center just be 5 in d4
yeah that was your King only one
actually you kind of prefer it on c1
right exactly exactly so line like this
you definitely don't want to see the
center blowing up when your king is
still stuck in the center on the e1
square so very sharp stuff Maurice
bring us up to date and the latest and
greatest of theory I for one am
perplexed by the move Queen a fight back
to d8 mm-hmm as well you should be this
position has been seen of course and
route d1 castles is the big main move
rook d1 the other move that we've seen
92 has been played though 263 times so
not a completely unexpected move by the
world champion it's not something that
Bobby has not seen before he certainly
studied but the move here normally is
Bishop back to e7 much more popular in
this position 166 times we're gonna give
you some numbers 166 times played the
other move is Bishop to b4 this one as
well taking advantage of this pin on
this line funky move played 88 times
almost half that other number Queen d8
six times six only Queen d8 played only
six times and in this position I'm
finding Shabalala
as the only player with black against
guy down off the name you mentioned
earlier
to a great us players to hall-of-famers
in faculty so they have played this
position as Chuvalo play the move Queen
to d8 it's only top-level game I found
in the line so far and I'm gonna have to
get my notation up here together while I
check that out
mmm a little bit of trouble there but we
will get to that position in a second ah
there we go so this move played in that
game route to d1 and we'll see
will this be a challenge Magnus I would
I believe in our game position Magnus
has to have been surprised really
surprised here by the move Queen to d8
he must have spent a lot of time on 92
looked at Bishop e7 looked at the move
of B for Bishop to b4 satisfied himself
with all the nuances in that line can
you imagine this third tier move played
once by top players six games only in
the database that you look at a book
like that you say that's rubbish
that's I'm not gonna look at that that's
a waste of my time and Fabi drops it on
the board almost instantly this is gonna
be a deep think again for Magnus has he
been outfoxed once again by Fabi or
legitimately is the move not necessarily
a great movement will give white an
opportunity to get an advantage my
feeling this is preparation by Fabi he
has been preparing extremely well and my
guess is that this is pure preparation
for him as this he just doesn't play
that fast if he doesn't know what he's
doing absolutely it makes sense if he
would have looked at 92 and came up with
this a little twist here was Queen to d8
it's funny because we've talked about
amazing backwards moves throughout this
event and we had a rook move that we
discussed rook a8 we talked about the
nice saving idea for Fabi saving having
to suffer with Bishop d2 and III check
that was a game where he looked like he
was starting to get a little worse after
kicking b6 that's right game PI right
and then there was also the night e1
check paint in that
and now we've finished the suite with
the backward Queen move the backward
Queen on a 5-2 d8 I'm still mystified
myself because it it feels like white
should earn a tempo or two to the good
after this move castles again this was a
variation made very popular by Gregory
cuyana
the Hall of Fame u.s. Grand Master that
Maurice mentioned a moment ago and the
idea behind castles very very
straightforward you're trying to react
to any central attack that black mimei
at the same time as soon as you put your
King on b1 you're ready to launch with
your own g4 g5 ideas and kings on
opposite flanks it's all about who can
attack the other player quicker and this
is a very double-edged line and I think
the better prepared player will do well
but I still think that castles valid
fused by I mean the position you're
talking about is right how did you're
saying Gregory played this with Knight
d2 no he not like castles after Queen
play castles okay right that's correct
now I'm looking at this game I pulled up
this game between Caetano and Chuvalo
from this feed a knockout World
Championship in Moscow in 2001 now it's
interesting because we got a lot of
notes on the side by Shabalala of
himself who played this line against
Gregory and he said in the line he said
when he played Queen 95 92 92 in this
position 92 was a big surprise for him
the position itself was a big surprise
for him and so he resorted to this move
Queen b8 which we have as dubious in
this annotations now doubts off is the
one who's given the annotations while
also giving shabbat loves impression of
the move as well so queen d is not
supposed to be a great move in this
position just like rook d1 our route d 8
excuse me in the in game 2
what's not supposed to be a good move
either so here we go again
moves that are supposed to be dubious
Matt Bobby is resurrecting and saying no
this this is good don't worry about it I
got ideas so now we see Queen d8
Shabalala have said the move rook t1 is
the most principled way to play and then
he played a novelty with 86 as Queen e7
had been played before and the line went
this way this way and Knight de for
given an exclamation mark in this
position so this is how that game
proceeded does Magnus know that line or
will he find it in the game and I'll
just go a couple more moves in the game
just let's get an example of what
happened there Bishop to d3 bishop YZ
Bishop e6 and then Knight takes on d5
whew nice let's get that on the board 9
takes on d5 as the bishop is hanging on
c5 and after takes now the move Queen
takes e5 was pointed and given as a
mistake has instead given his Bishop 8 7
check is much better King h8 ok my boy
are there where you go my board is slow
for some reason King h8 no yeah my board
is fighting with me today let me just
get this back Bishop 8 7 King h8 alright
guys my board is not being cool all
right here we go and rook takes d5 as
the superior way to play in this
position and it gets really sharp from
here but loving white is the final
analysis as white is stolen upon and
black not showing adequate counter play
so this is the kind of line you would
look at if you were lesser player than
Fabi and say hmm looking good for for
her black looking good for white there
I'm not going down that route right but
2001 engines were not as strong as they
are now so you can note that he will
look at it look at it deeply and be
satisfied with this move Queen b8
otherwise he's not playing such a move
cuz it would just be bad for him so what
surprise does he have in store from
Magnus
Thank You Maurice and in this game of
cat-and-mouse of opening theory and
who is better prepared one of the things
that happened in my generation if I came
to the game and my opponent surprised me
with what we would call a theoretical
novelty it usually meant that I was
going to go into the tank for 30 minutes
and try to really understand what this
novel approach means so whenever you saw
somebody really going into a deep think
in the opening they really meant that
they had been surprised and an opening
novelty had been played on the board
well after this MOOC queen d8 which
isn't really in a theoretical novelty it
was certainly a surprise move
Magnus did not go into any kind of deep
think that Magnus very quickly has
responded with the move Knight d2 b3
which is a kind of indication that Queen
d8 even though it's a third-tier type of
move it's a little familiar to him as
well well and he also does look like a
direct refutation like he's just gonna
kill the thing but this move has also
been played played three times in the
database Bishop e7 being the
auto-response and two moves here rook d1
or castles in this position we only have
one real high-level example okay now I'm
seeing that by transposition there been
other games as well the still the
high-level example is still one player
go load against gifts Kovich Tisdel
Jonathan tis must be happy right now
because he has himself seen a Jonathan
Tisdale was one of our colleagues a
journalist of a very famous writer as
well so he's gonna be happy to see this
position say hey wait a minute I've been
here before and not only that he won the
six games that I see right now from this
position after Bishop to e7 which we
expect to happen on the board there been
six games the score six Oh white six
zero why does one every game at least in
our database which has millions of games
up to seven million games six zero for
white is Fabi did Fabi look at this move
Knight b3
it looks like Magnus did look at it
played relatively
quickly and hmm it's getting curiouser
and curiouser in here well don't don't
keep us pining how did white score so
very well after the move Bishop e7 well
why did you rip d1 or did he do it with
castles castles has been the major move
there's no one single refutation as rook
d1 is also scored castles has been the
major move from this book d1 has been
the major move I said said that wrong
rook d1 has been the major move castles
played once so rook d1 the major move
and black has tried everything like has
tried a5 but like its ride a5 black is
tried Bishop d7 black has tried rook e8
like it's tried everything here and none
of the moves became what's up to snuff
not a single move was up to snuff in
this position
what does Fabi have against this Knight
b3 if it's a surprise to him he could be
in serious trouble already
that's that's a bit of a strange thing
to see him go down this path I'm gonna
see what the engines think about this
position and look at this it gets even
more interesting as he has played the
move Bishop to b6 this is a novelty in
our database Bishop to b6 and the bishop
is always gone back to e7 and played
pretty quickly by Fabi as well right
what is going on in this position the
engines think that this position is
equal no problems for black we're
talking 0.08 when you don't even have a
point 1 to start you got nothing and the
engine saying this position is fine for
black super sharp you can see the
distribution of pieces tells you it's
sharp the pawn structure is asymmetric
pieces are all over the place white
hasn't castled yet so to call it equal
is not one of those equal boring
snoozefest oh no this is it's equal but
you better know your stuff because this
could get wild in a second and this move
Bishop to b6 will indeed come as a
surprise to Magnus and we talk about
surprises that one's gonna come as a
surprise what's going on guys we have a
rich game here in Game seven of the
World Championship okay my understanding
when I studied these positions in my day
is that the bishop
on c5 had gone like you were saying
Maurice automatically back to the e7
square and the reason why in my
generation thought that was an automatic
is because black wanted to avoid the
Bishop to g5 pin in other words you
didn't in such positions play Bishop e6
because you were perpetually afraid of
this move Bishop g5 and that the squared
e5 would become weak there are ideas of
Bishop takes f6 and C takes d5 and the
idea is you kind of wanted to sit
frankly to avoid a situation like this
where this pin on f6 is just simply
really annoying after the move Bishop h4
yeah sure you could play g5 but nobody
was really happy weakening their their
King position so hey I'm just saying
that the approach that the grandmasters
in my day took was that to exploit the
bishop being on the b6 square you would
play the move Bishop g5 to take
advantage of the pin
there's no Bishop e7 anymore okay now
how consequent and how real is the
advantage well we know the chess engines
today have made it such that it's almost
impossible to get an advantage with the
white pieces against a really really
good defense yeah so your knee-jerk
response to the move Bishop g5 might be
what would you go h6 g5 it's not that
easy is it for you for for black to
continue here yeah it is it's kind of
surprising it's annoying
so another point of why the bishop is
not good on b6 and it's a little bit
hidden is there's no B 7 B 5 well I mean
that's obvious but what do I mean by
that a lot of times when you capture on
c4
well I will play Bishop takes c4
and that's rather clear right right but
I can also in such positions play night
on v3 - D - and this is really annoying
because now when I recapture with the
night I'll be hitting the bishop I'll be
hitting the d6 square and I'll be able
to play rook do you want yeah I have
time to play here in 95 and 96 to break
the pin right and and normally if your
Bishop wasn't on b6 there would be a
move like d7 b5 which would put the
kibosh on this idea no yeah okay you
could go Knight e5 or even maybe in that
other line I'm thinking of like the
typical were Lopez idea that well I was
thinking instead of I guess I don't I
guess okay so you're only 92 here and
this one but I I was thinking if you
were taken with okay I was Bishop 95
right with the ID of 96 right so I can
so just two four eight six first and
then 96 and and then the idea is in this
way you could break the pill I'm fine
now well right I can go over t1 Queen
he's well yeah I'm saying I want to get
into tempo rook d1 so I'm seizing the
open file with a gain of tempo and that
can't be bad and now you know I am
eyeballing that d6 square you did break
the pit and that was a good thing
without having to play G and you didn't
have to resort to g5 but it's not like
you're still out of the wood no I
haven't stopped Bishop d6 maybe maybe
play Bishop c7 yeah so yeah but there's
still some problems some tactics
possibly right with that Knight moving
and discovering an attack on the bishop
but okay so but you were saying I mean
even more sharp line that after takes on
c4 you might just play 82 right exactly
I like this move Knight d2 a lot once
again I I do want to recapture this pawn
but I want to recapture it on my terms
and with my knight being on c4 instead
of on b3 it's like in a nicer aggressive
square it's reaching into the position
d6
it's at
getting the bishop on b6 and this Bishop
is not that great on c4 the bishop will
come to e2 and f3 will have a lot more
potency so I see that there's still
problems even though the computer is
saying zero zero eight as a human player
I look at the move Bishop g5 and I say
okay concretely what am I supposed to do
Maurice wasn't knowing what is baby
supposed to do
I mean and I'm sure the engine is going
to show us the way and it's not again we
mentioned that the idea of the equal
assessment by the engine does not mean
that this position is easy right it
means the position in the engines
estimations after analyzing all the
possibilities that it can within its
range of capabilities saying this
position should be fine for black but
boy go find all those moves but the move
Bishop b6 is so provocative right it's
it's the move and you put your finger on
it Bishop to g5 and from a human players
perspective to allow the strategic move
Bishop g5 that is what it is it's not
tactical in strategic it's applying
pressure to the position so you can get
a positional advantage make black give
some kind of concessions with capture it
is indeed this positional pressure being
applied to his position that makes the
bishop belong on e7 not on b6
Oh b6 is just dogged determination
saying I want to play this move d4 and I
don't care about your other moves right
I don't want to go to e7 and go passive
so Magnus you know and he saw this
novelty with rook to d1 to DA
yeah he had an expletive in his response
to this new move he's like you can't be
doing things like that and oh no I'm in
preparation Bishop e6 has that same
quality and maybe even more so because
it just it's just so stubborn it's like
I don't care about you and I'm and I'm
prepared here to will he show it once
again with the black pieces as Magnus is
deep in thought let's go to your line
Bishop g5 8 6 is the first move to look
at guys bit of a wrinkle this move
chasing the bishop back so you can unpin
yourself later let's go into this
sacrifice Bishop f6 queen of 6c d5
looking to win upon
whoa 97 suddenly looking to take
advantage of blacks lead in development
the king is still stuck in the middle of
the board you've given me the extra
bishop if you want to get greedy and
capture this pawn then be ready to face
off against these monsters Bishop here
Bishop here works coming to the file
with a quickness and blacks gonna say I
got play I got really good playing facts
this Knight is dominated when the rooks
land we're looking like rook lands on c8
Knights going to d5 you might have to
trade and just allow pressure everywhere
so that's a huge bit of compensation
black will have in that line and the
other point is after CB 597 if you
decide to keep this he could still play
Knight d5 and again it's about the speed
of development for the black pieces that
white will have to contend with this is
just happening so fast and this d6 pawn
doesn't inspire confidence as one that's
going to survive when it's all said and
done so this position is one that Magnus
will be looking at and I can predict
he's gonna be looking for awhile if he's
not looking for a safe line but eight
six
it gets even sharper in your line as
Wendy takes c4 in this position 92
Knight e5
give me the pawn I want to keep it
castles well Bishop d7 I'll go down this
main line knight de for getting very
sharp and look at this g5 if Magnus has
to calculate this line there's gonna be
a lot of work I had a lot of brain power
Bishop g3 93 check takes takes Queen
takes d3 94-98 c4 Queen takes and now
this wrinkle their other moves as well
Queen to e8 getting off this pin saying
yeah okay you got me with some stuff
here I'm gonna get mine as well my
bishop is also gonna go on the long
diagonal wild wild West's play in this
position now this is just scratching the
surface and this human challenge this
human champion will have to look at it
realize that his opponent has looked at
this even deeper than this casual looked
at i've given with an engine so he's
looked at it even deeper may have spent
a day or two looking at all the lines
and so i'm giving all these engine lines
you might be like memory slots engine
lines
yeah but Fabi has all of them on it's
fine
and Magnus is now sitting there going
whoa what is right here is this am I
better or is this guy just I'll prepared
me and black is fine this is a very
difficult challenge to face for the
first time on this chess board no
question very exciting and even in that
final position you had that rook on f8
in a trap position there's Bishop d6 to
win an exchange
that's wild and crazy but we have a
phone call yes welcome to the show our
first caller of the day from Virginia
happy Sunday
hey happy Sunday thank you for having me
on I have a quick question
he was we're seeing a lot of draws in
this this match and also in previous
World Championship you feel that that's
because these players are so skilled and
so evenly matched or do you feel that
they're not really pushing for a win in
every single game and you're have more
decided to play some safer lines that
end up in a lot of draws thank you for
the question let me take the first crack
at that by happenstance today I looked
at a article on the chess base website
by Lars Bou Hansen and it was the IBD I
think that was right in accuracies IMB
inaccuracies mistakes and blunders and
it was a retrospective of the 2016 World
Championship match in New York between
Sergey and Magnus and the idea is you
have a chess engine who's giving you all
the perfect moves and an inaccuracy is a
move that throws away four tenths of a
pawn right a mistake is a move that
throws away one one and then a blunder
is like one and a half one half plus
right and it was something like they
played 700 moves in New York and it was
like there was 15 inaccuracies you know
seven mistakes and four blunders in
other words chess obviously at the start
were in equilibrium I mean it's an equal
position and for some player to win
you have to disturb the equilibrium to
such an extent that I have a decisive
advantage right and you have to make a
lot of inaccuracies a lot of mistakes
and even sometimes a blunder and it's
just that these guys are so good they
don't make enough mistakes to give their
opponent the decisive advantage that's a
great point yes and if you take that a
question from the caller and you go back
to World Championships past right like
how do you think the imb score of a book
well obviously the imb score if you go
to the start 1886 it was high yes right
if you and then it's going to go lower
and lower and lower and lower and lower
till today you're getting to a position
where literally in that match between
Sergey and madness it was something like
I may have got it wrong five perfect
games Wow and what do you think about
this both players play perfectly there's
a part of you that feels that this match
is even a higher quality but then also I
wonder if it'll do quite as good on that
scale just because we've had such long
games and then I guess technically the
engine will say that five you made a
mistake or a blunder yesterday by not an
accuracy this made in 36 that's right
but it seems that - um even better the
scale could be even better if at some
point it accounts for the difficulty of
seeing the mistakes that's right exactly
for instance a profound is that idea to
trap your own items exactly I mean come
on you gotta give that a high degree of
difficulty right because yeah I think I
heard of one case where somebody thought
their opponent might be cheating because
all their moves were matching up with
the computer but it was like a type of
position where it was like really easy
to find the computer moves right
Aquarius is a narrow path exactly where
it was yeah just a more dry position
where it was easier to find them whereas
as UN garry kasparov by the way made the
exact same joke you did so great minds
think alike right but after yesterday's
draw he said that if Bobby were to find
that line it was just so beyond
brilliant then a lot of people would be
like what on earth yeah every police
agency in the world would be trying to
find a chip-in fabiana's body or his
brain for like for like curing cancer
exactly exactly but over to you Maurice
what do you got for us
well the last time that Magnus faced off
against a shocking surprising novelty in
this line he played the move Bishop to
e2 rook d8 landed on the board and he
said he had to go full grovel and play
the move Bishop to e2 well we see it yet
again in this game as Bishop b6 has
happened he did not play the most
testing move Bishop g5 the way everyone
wanted to see him do in the other game
after rook to d8 to play the most
testing move he said now I'm 92 it was
it was the most testing but I didn't
want to go into some crazy preparation
after some thought he played this move
which to my eyes looked very tepid
indeed the loss of a tempo if black
would simply capture on c4 which black
does even in the Bishop g5 line where
you think about it so here if you had
actually put the bishop on g5 we did
throwing this little wrinkle of of h6
bishop h4 now black plays takes
according to the engines at least and
goes about to play that wild Sharpe
position that we looked at which the
more by the way I looked at it with the
engine white was getting a bit of an
edge with that weak King side we had
looked at that line but here without
Bishop g5 with just Bishop e2 a lot more
quiet choice insisting the bishop will
be better on this square the inches are
saying this move is not as good but
Magnus again avoiding the theory
avoiding the sharp preparation that Fabi
asked for him and said let's just play
this position as well Willie start
getting frustrated this is three three
whites to go and if this one is a draw
with only 12 two whites will be
remaining obviously and Fabiano can say
again success I've prepared this guy I'm
getting good
a black black it's almost like you want
to give the guy white every game it
looks like in this match as white as
maybe gotten what two games we decided
yeah maybe was all it was that asked at
best that English that he kept an edge
throughout I think that's it I I can't
even think of another game where white
had the edge throughout it looks like
Black has been in cruise control in this
match and in fact could have won two
games already so what's going on it's
modern chess changing things I mean
there's a lot of rationality we can have
but if white is not getting anything at
the elite level then something's going
on in preparation and the reality of
having the black pieces well I feel in
some ways that Magnus is getting psyched
out in the sense that you know he
obviously is aware that if I be on as a
great preparation great opening
theoretician and as using his engines
along with his teams and somehow he's
backing off the most challenging
approaches to positions out of some fear
that he'll be playing against the engine
and not against his opponent so I look
at this position and really I see three
candidate choices the first one I see is
the move Bishop g5 I think that's very
challenging the second very very
challenging choice I see is castles long
again taking a page from Gregory katana
and finally the third most challenging
move I see to blacks position as the
move rook d1 so again I see Bishop g5
castles and rook d1 as the three moves
that are gonna put the most pressure on
my opponent and then I'm gonna choose
out of those three candidate moves one
of them that I think will was really the
best and then suddenly I see this month
along yeah that's that really scares me
when I'm playing against it a well
prepared to phone in and I haven't
looked at it before well I shall remove
Bishop e2 and I'm saying Magnus is
clearly choosing that move because
he has a fear that by playing into the
sharp variations he's going to battle on
out might work against a lesser player
but the problem with 5ee is not only
good at the opening he's hanging in
there toe-to-toe in every type of
position with Magnus's far in fact Ramos
has not proven anything and quite the
contrary yeah game sexy outplayed and
from an equal position to build up a
winning image to point out we are
rooting for Fabiano we do we are
recording the show in st. Louis where
father now lives but in terms of the
chess
we're being objective what maxes out
played Fabi like in game why oh it was
fantastic that was played there was
another game which was really impressive
where Bobby played the b4 line in the
Sicilian for sack that's a yeah that's
at the great botolan one of those hands
about well he's about to do this take
out your claws he's pulling back is kind
of shirt you know kind of to do one of
these things I like that though that's a
good apparently press is only allowed
photo photographers are only allowed in
for the first five minutes so you have
this like little short window no doubt
some of the great photographers in chess
Eric Rosen who's been taking the photos
for this live stream as well as for us
chess and then we also have of course
David yada who's on the team who's a
very well-known and I believe Leonard is
there as well so yeah we don't know from
of course the grand Chester but anyway
as I was saying that game five Magnus
played spectacularly getting getting put
on the defensive by Magnus by by
father's incredible preparation it
almost feels like when he has to do it
he goes for the sharpest lines and plays
it but now that he's white he's choosing
he doesn't really have to so he's
choosing not to do it that makes any
sense
yeah but I'm saying his backing off is
limiting himself and his ability to play
for an advantage like if you play Bishop
e2 and you play tap attempt attempt it
in a position that's calling for well it
literally demands that you play sharply
you can't expect to walk away with an
advantage now the question is
Maurice those challenging moves that we
mentioned Bishop g5 rook d1 castles
would any of them brought Magnus and
edge if he had gone down those paths and
I've been looking at it as well and I'm
gonna play some moves and you're not
gonna be happy okay movies up here on
the board with these challenging lines
let's start with castles okay that's the
council challenge that's a very
challenging looking move you're putting
pressure on this deep on we're gonna
ramp up the pressure until the guy
ignores you and plays the move Queen e7
okay and says you want to try taking
that pawn because if you do you're gonna
get in some deep trouble
after this move Bishop e6 and blacks
putting a rook on c8 and there's gonna
be some kind of discovery and you still
haven't develop your pieces on this side
of the board you will need to move your
King and black is huge
in this position black in fact winning
this position the machine is going to
come with such a thud and authority and
the discovery is not going to be just
for the pin but on your queen as well so
this one's actually done you can't touch
the pawn yeah the other line is you
mentioned after Bishop e6 rook to d1
still Queen to e7 no you have in castles
but then doesn't care you want to try
taking this pawn again same deal Bishop
e7 okay your Kings not here but it looks
going to appear on c8 after your rook on
d5 moves and the same tactics start yet
again as you are way down in development
on this side what that means is that you
cannot touch this pawn on d5 at all it's
just safe and because it's safe it means
blacks gonna be able to take on see for
himself or you're gonna have to give him
something here Bishop the Queen e7 let
me get rook e1 in the board Queen e7
what do you do because he plans now to
capture bring the bishop I'll bring
bring the rooks to the game as soon as
possible and he can capture and also
play with rook d8 this one is not easy
guys and in fact if Magnus had to look
at this and realize that there were
sacrificial possibilities and his
opponents blame this quickly he's
thinking that's not a way to play
because he can't evaluate that position
easily and even the inches are saying
it's not good for white or maybe a
little smidgen but not much so why go
down these testing lines when your
opponent clearly has that prepared
only issue is this move Bishop to g5 and
this one as we mentioned gets sharp
immediately with the move eight-six and
captures captures in this position so
sorry you played you played actually 92
here with the move 95 right this one is
some crazy stuff right and do you really
want to go into it again so when you've
been are prepared what do you do I mean
you don't you you can't lose this game
no if he loses with white with five
games to go he could be in deep trouble
remember though he did lose in game 8
against Kuryakin in the last match so
it's not like it's over but to just lose
AB the opening itself lose the game but
not on the opening that happened to him
in game 3 of his World Championship
match against Anan if you remember that
novelty that in that nimzo-indian I
believe it was that was sprung on him by
I no no we're gonna have uh not on the
show very shortly so he's gonna be able
to talk about that the opening issues as
we'll see him in the next hour
there's five-time world champion who's
watching this match very closely and
he's seen a few matches in his day so he
can give us a lot of insights as to what
is going on in the players minds and
what happens when you face off against a
big novelty so that that will be a
fascinating in insights fascinating
sights that we're gonna get from Vichy I
don't know yes I might play Bishop e2
myself but I saw this position if it was
like a regular game yeah yeah but the
World Championship match game 7 Fabiano
Caruana playing quickly well ok hold on
okay a couple of things let's go back
and forth first of all yeah we do
Khomeini seven first of all they've
already played wan Queens gambit
declined with Bishop f4 so Magnus was
prepared this time and he came with
Knight d2 and he had been looking at the
variation and he clearly had gotten to
this maybe he didn't look deeply at
Queen a5 I mean who would doubtlessly he
spent most of his attention on the move
Bishop c5 to b4 as well as Bishop e7 the
two most popular moves then after
Queen a 593 again he probably did not
spend a lot of attention on the move
that was played in the game which was
Bishop b6 but he certainly has a great
familiarity with this position now
Maurice if I could just take you down
this game one more time this line one
more time and that was castles long and
I thought that that Bishop g5 rook
deewan castles long with the most
challenging you mentioned queen e7 now I
will never open up the game with my King
on c1 I'm not interested in that pond
I'd play the move king b1 and I would
think that this is a really sharp and
challenging position for both players I
would imagine you black would play the
move rook da yeah and then I would play
the move also the move also move aged
six despoiling right I was about to say
after up d8 I was gonna play Bishop g5
so maybe h7 h6 but I bring my king to b1
and I'm starting to look at you you may
recall the the the Jonathan Spellman
Nigel short candidates World
Championship candidates match with G to
g4 I'm starting to think okay we're on
opposite flanks and I'll go ahead on the
on the kingside what you want to do is
just let us move now yeah okay
a couple moves one is to capture another
one is to play the move e5 justify this
play right g5 you wanna play g5 now yeah
what is the whole idea
okay so let's be clear you are playing a
world championship match of course
you're in the position just blue-blue
analyze this now with us sitting here
naturally but this position that you
just waltzed into yeah with the guy you
it's just you have no suspicion whether
or not he's prepared the most critical
moves in the position and castles is
undoubtedly the single most critical
move in this position and notice Queen
e7 is on the board so he knew the idea
was to play Queen e7 right yeah so this
is so he knows this is pneumatic Queen
e7 so you've walked you BAE
you know we have all the heart we're
sitting in analysis but you're at the
board and you know if I play castles
he's ready yeah it's not like he has you
didn't look at this move you're not like
oh my god castles who would have played
that right no castles is on the board as
the most natural way to try to kill the
guy and play the sharp chess so now this
is what we call high stakes this is I
say the whole thing you're gonna go for
it right now because you think game 7 is
the critical game and you're gonna just
bust this move Bishop to b6 that's right
i I think Magnus is far more practical
he's shown himself to be far more
practical than that as matter of fact
after this move already the engines
playing Tate's
talked about everything being on priest
I mean the knight is hanging the night
over here this bishop is hanging let's
go down this line yeah takes on b3 in
here your king on b1 is a problem
because after it takes of course yeah
that's in the middle and now the move
rook e8 is being given as his Bishop is
hanging and so you just walked into this
line yeah it turned out that it was just
sharp and maybe just equal in the end in
fact maybe better for black as black
looks like about to win a pawn excuse me
Black's winning a pawn so you can't just
walk into the line it just plays a
couple of casual moves as the game is
just super super sharp right and for
Magnus II just oops his trip over a
blunder and there he goes yeah well I
admit it but no I'm saying that Magnus
has seen this defense already he knows
that 92 rook t1 and castles are the most
challenging types of moves in these
middle game positions so I'm thinking
Magnus and his team have done their
preparation as well it should be six no
not necessarily against they should be
saying really talk about that move but
at the move Bishop c6 is so challenging
but some kind of familiarity with these
middle game's positions so like in the
game
today oh hold on read now oh well now
that he's played we should be too that
doesn't do what I wanted to say know
what I had what I did want to say
however was that in my view fabbi has
taken a very provocative setup with the
bishop on b6 and he's basically said to
white if you don't play these moves
Bishop g5 and rook d1 and castles long
you're not really challenging me correct
and I'll get a pretty easy equality so
back up I see where you're going with
that the way you've worded that right
you're you're an artful wordsmith okay I
want to go down your logical line I want
to say the other way I'm gonna play
Bishop to b6 and I have prepared for
your major moves in this position the
bishop I dare you to play the main the
Bishop g5 the castles the rook d1 I dare
you to play those challenging move
because I am ready for those moves that
I think is the word you should have in
his mind because remember when Fabi was
asked about the move rook d8 in game 2
his response was oh yeah you know it's
very complicated
right right that's real clarity wait
we're gonna clear things up for the
journalists right there Fabi probably
saying I'm not telling you guys a thing
right i sat in my laboratory with my
boys and a supercomputer and we looked
at these moves and try what I got
try me I dare you come bring it and see
what happens and that's what Magnus is
facing off against he knows there's no
question Magnus knows if he was playing
this blitz let's call it like the
Grantchester wrapping blades
say really let me see even if I'm wrong
even if I'm wrong I want to see I just
want to see it because I don't believe
you
here he can't afford to be wrong he
cannot walk into the main lines and then
find out that he's actually worse by
some tactical Sharpe like that sharp
line we just went through a just down
upon for being mr. bravado so I think
yes sir it's easy for
right now to look at this and and talk
about it because we don't have to play
the moves on the board from Magnus the
practical decision is Bishop e2 anything
else is okay I'm not saying it's
suicidal maybe that's a bit much but
it's walking into fathers preparation
Wow
well I mean that's why we've been seeing
six games and each time it keeps ramping
up every draw means that now the players
are going to be less and less inclined
to take risks if you if you don't take
risks in Game seven you're not gonna be
taking a lot of risk in game 10 if the
match is still tied Magnus certainly not
and and Magnus doesn't need to come on
we know if he can get out of this to the
rapid and blitz for a bridge yeah so why
gamble your games away when you may
never see rapid um blitz where you are
at the edge it's not saying that he's
playing for rapid in blitz but he
doesn't have to take a chance
not right now that's why I match play so
different to the caller's point that's
why I match plays so different from
tournament chess in tournament chess you
you might say let me go into the crazier
lines if I lose this game I may not see
this guy again I'll play four other guys
five other guys and I'll beat one of
them
this guy I'm seeing every day he's my
equal basically I think everybody
starting to warm to the idea that Fabi
in classical chess is probably Magnus is
equal right some might even argue hey
wait a minute
yeah maybe theoretically better where is
Magnus better than him actually but
let's say they're equal the ratings say
that why do you want to toss a win to
this guy I mean and then he gets white
tomorrow it might be ready with some
some other novelty on you know way I
think that he made the practical
decision that's normal for him and no
reason for him to play those crazy sharp
lines
hmm not that I don't want to see those
lines I would have preferred to see that
stuff that stuff with g4 and g5 yeah
sure that was fun now for the
commentators we're gonna have a lot of
insight on this is Vishy Anand it's fine
to be on the break that we have him as a
guest Wow
the great world champions and one of the
great theoreticians as well so he really
understands these kinds of conversations
that we're having about the sharp
opening oh yeah I mean it just it'll be
really interesting to see what is she
used to say and that's an understatement
yeah absolutely stay tuned with us we
are gonna be back after the break
shortly thereafter we'll have the one
and only
Avicii Anand and we're gonna leave you
with the top American players and their
thoughts on the match yeah absolutely
amazing for the chess in the u.s. he
came extremely close two years ago to
winning but Sergei played a great
tournament and he also deserved a knee
and he played a great match against
Magnus but this time it's Fabiano's
chance yeah I mean it's definitely very
exciting it's the first time that the
United States has had a challenger in
over a generation so the last challenger
was Bobby Fischer
that was quite a while ago it'll be
pretty exciting to see if he could
return the throne or if he can you know
challenge Magnus and be able to win
because I would think Fabio Khurana has
definitely had some very strong
performances over the years so you know
he's definitely a very good Challenger
for Magnus
um I mean Fabiana has been playing quite
well so he certainly has chances I don't
think he's anywhere near 50% contrary to
what he said but that being said Magnus
he hasn't been that impressive of late
and he also isn't playing that much so
it's it's hard to tell what what sort of
shape Magnus is gonna be in but I think
more than anything it's it's gonna
really depend more on the quality of
Magnus's play than the Fabiano's played
Magnus plays up to the level that he's
capable of I think his odds are probably
85 90 % but that being said Magnus he's
he's had some ups and downs and
certainly his match against Sergei was
far tougher than anyone expected so so
it'll be interesting interesting to see
yes of course I max I'm excited that's
like American players played yeah I
think it's very interesting again all
its will probably boost popularity of
chess in America for the tournament for
the candidates tournament I was
predicting Fabiano I was hoping Fabiana
would win and I was also predicting that
he seemed the most likely and obviously
he played great I'm really happy that
there's an American playing for the
World Championship which hasn't I mean
I've never seen it in my lifetime so
it's gonna be really exciting
obviously it's tough he's up against one
of the best players in chess history but
I think if anyone right now has a chance
he's definitely one of the few guys who
has a chance against Magnus I mean it
was amazing personally for me because I
know Fabiano and you know I was watching
his game I was following the tournament
very closely I was just glued to my
computer watching the LAT last game like
I even though I knew he was winning
until it was done like I just couldn't
stop watching it I think it means a lot
to the US because it's been so long
since we have someone competing for the
world championship title I think it'd be
amazing to have a world champion there'd
be a lot more interest hopefully
there'll be a lot of more mainstream
media coverage so channel just can
become more mainstream and people I
think Bobby Fischer is like a household
name so it'd be really nice for if I
beyond that to become a name that people
and you think of chess and you can say
oh yeah five beyond the Quran he's
either challenging the world champion or
Houston you want champion I think it's
great that he won the candidates and
he's going to be a clay
or World Chess Champion because like we
haven't had an American like chess
champion for a long time so I think
could be really nice to see someone from
the US actually win the title and it
could be like Bobby Fischer again well
it's definitely and really exciting that
avianna is the world challenger and even
people who don't play chess know they
know and they ask me questions they go
have you heard about that no yeah and
he's actually from simply snow so we're
really proud of him and now to have an
American World Chess Championship
challenger I mean that's huge you know I
mean I was following the candidates horn
with a lot of interests and I was very
happy to see Fabiano win and for us to
have an American challenger and it's
gonna be great for tests because it's
gonna be another number one number two
players in the world playing could be
really great to watch st. Louis
University celebrating its 200th
anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the st. Louis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
teens inception
SLU obtained second best University at
the pan-american intercollegiate Chess
Championships higher purpose greater
good st. Louis University be surprised
be intrigued be delighted the world
chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love
three galleries highlight the history
culture and creativity behind the game
explore chess in ways you never imagined
it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our World
Championship coverage where we have what
looks like it's gonna be one of the most
exciting middle games that we have yes
between Magnus Carlsen and Fabiano
Carolina and this what's turning out to
be epic we well fought and tight world
championship match you were criticizing
Magnus a little bit softly through the
movement should be to saying hey if you
want to get something with okay or
somewhere in between my eventual of
being explosive but it also has the
potential being a very very quiet you
know game position as well could go
either way
yes but it's funny because we've had so
many thrilling and games in this match
but we've been yet to have and all holds
barred middle game like that yeah so we
can't complain about our end game
lessons but hey let's get let's get a
little wild with queenside castles but
he did play magnets did play your idea
Bishop g5 active one move later than you
wanted to play it but still looking very
exciting as we go to Maurice yes a
principled move you've been talking
about all this time this move Bishop to
g5 Bishop e2 suggested that he didn't
want to play Bishop to g5 as he could
have done it before he wanted to get
away from all that stuff but he's done
it now and so the move Bishop g5 on the
board
rook t1 is something that the engine at
least stockfish preferred when we go to
ceci which is a Norwegian supercomputer
it is looking at this position and it
always follows Magnus's games and and if
anything is doing live and analyzes them
in depth and you see all this computer
speak here lots of possibilities for
block but the move it likes the best is
to take on c4 and it says that actually
black is slightly better but I mean
smidgen not even point 1.09 better by
capturing on c4 right now so Bishop g5
not a main test as far as the computer
is concerned and it gives 92 and 95 as
the way to play let's get back to
something we can see a little bit
clearer takes and Knight d2
95 as black is fully mobilized this is
the thing to notice these pieces are
ready only needs to bring the bishop
into the game to d7 and then the rooks
will fly in very quickly white needs to
castle and get rooks in as well but
without the pressure of that Senator
Paul and the problem of the D pawn will
disappear has disappeared then what is
white playing for maybe some kind of
disharmony in the black camp that you
can look at potentially a pin on this
diagonal a move like Knight to e4 could
happen at any point to try to put a
little bit of pressure on this diagonal
looking for anything but black is even
willing to allow double pawns around his
King and not worry about that position
either as white will have to prove that
there's something substantial here it
looks like there's nothing it looks like
it's a rich position in that all these
pieces are on the board but pawn
structure speaks a lot imbalances speak
a lot and if black walks out of this
without any real imbalances or problems
coordinating his pieces we're talking
easy draw for black now I did predict an
easy draw in the last game when they had
that simplified position and how wrong I
was in that position it turned out in to
be a brawl sharp possibility where Bobby
could have won the game but we know
chess I mean justice complex so affirm
that it may if he can get out of all
these issues then the draw will be
closer at hand but as we've seen these
players are playing 50 60 80 100 moves
just to try for that elusive win Thank
You Maurice very exciting news we have
Vichy Annan five-time world champion on
the line with us we've one of our
favorites here in st. Louis but it's
great to have you on the line Vichy
thank you so much for taking time sure
let's just join oh you great great well
first of them what is surprised you
about the match so far was there
anything you've seen that you weren't
expecting I mean a match can go in many
different ways right now it seems
extremely balanced and that makes I
think Magnus is game one miss all the
more expensive because
and I partially felt this myself he
might have felt that as long as he's
creating chances eventually he would
score but he's not managed to create
many chances after that so that with
hindsight Game one was a lot more
valuable than he realized I think were
you watching live in Game one and we
were you shocked when he didn't wasn't
able to convert we actually had Gary on
the line and he was pointing out all the
best moves
I mean Magnus is one of these players
who finds the difficult stuff easily and
it's it even seems simple to me I mean I
tried to look at it with I mean I wasn't
looking with an engine and while there
are details to be worked out it didn't
seem particularly difficult so that yeah
that's a Miss I mean there's no way of
getting around that that's a Miss I mean
you always try to think is this easy
without an engine let me try and think
for myself are there details I'm missing
and so on but game one was fairly simple
I mean route III isn't that difficult
also so and and the way that Fabiana
escaped with Queen takes F for f7 is
also not difficult so some waiting for
the Queen side you know b5 king b6
they're very very strange missed by
Magnus what about yesterday Vichy can
you believe that Fabi missed the maid in
36 I mean it's just shocking I I'm still
trying to understand what's wrong with
every other night move because I mean
Bishop and Knight you essentially think
it's a question of driving a king
somewhere you don't realize that there
are only moves in the position once
Black has an extra piece then it's just
a in fact the knight will have several
routes to the same square you can go by
r3 or c6 or c2 or you know so for me
it's hard to understand why Bishop H
first so unique I am going to look at it
more closely at some point but I mean I
think even if Abby had found Bishop I'd
sure he would not have found the whim
visi you have been preparing for World
Championship matches almost your whole
professional life and this occurred in
this game an incident that we're very
curious about what your feeling is when
Fabi played this move Bishop to b6 which
was not the natural movers to move Queen
D and then Bishop to b6 what is your
feeling about the fact that Magnus
ducked the principle line as he did in
game 2 here as well especially with the
white pieces well at the board you had
you have to rethink everything even if
you have looked at it it might you your
head is full of lines so you want to
clarify your thoughts and sometimes you
may want to be just sensible so I don't
think it's necessary for him to
necessarily charge into the main line
besides he seems to have a small edge
right now so you think it was just a
practical decision on his part as
opposed to avoiding what could have been
a very dangerous preparation yes and the
Magnus can do this sometimes he I think
he's going for his kind of position he's
done it with me as well very often
there's a move that scared scared me
from the other side and he would often
just do something sensible so he might
have seen something or he may have just
done it down into two crumbs
he also prepared you want a big game
through preparation game three off your
match against him is that something that
that he's scared of potentially as well
just walking into some preparation he
said that he had that expletive about
rook d8 in game two that he just
something he just does not want to see
his preparation by the opponent well who
does yeah perhaps there was a time when
some people were more afraid of seeing
preparation than others but by now
computers have gotten so far ahead that
I think we all dread ending up in
someone's home prep so that doesn't
surprise me at all and also if the
alternative to the main line is simply
something that
your style then then that's an extra to
go for it
Vichy first of all congratulations on
your victory in the Tata blitz
tournament in India still winning
tournaments after all of these years I
see that's very very nice inspiring old
old fogies like myself what I wanted to
ask you Vichy I remember very clearly in
Bonn in 2008 your World Championship
match against Vladimir Kramnik which you
won decisively but you want it
decisively with the black pieces and it
strikes me something strange about this
match as well that black is really
dictating the play and neither player is
getting an advantage with white sheer
with us if you can what what do you
think about the fact that the players
have been so mhm that that neither
player is getting advantage with white
and what's the reasons for that well
2008 was exceptional because if you
actually saw how kramnik played in Game
one that's what I expected him to do
most of the time in Game one he he saw
the Slav now before the match of course
he has checked the Slav because it's one
of my principle openings but he didn't
know which sub variation he didn't know
what to expect so the first game you're
kind of looking for information he then
played the exchange Slav did something
risk free and the idea was I'll go back
home revise all the lines now that I
know what I can roll out expect less and
we'll go from there
right what was amazing for me was
essentially I was baiting him I wanted
him to get into this line the shop
Mehran but exactly for that I had no
hope whatsoever of getting it on the
border but Vlad II went to it like a
moth to the flame I mean he just kept on
hammering you he hammered for tool games
in that line not Intel is that
justification because by game 5 it had
become clear that the line was starting
to become
and in fact it's hardly been played
since hmm but we still had an
information advantage in Game three Game
four I much less but perhaps there was a
little bit left so I would say Game
three it was very nice for me that he
wandered into this game five well I was
gambling as well because repeating a
line he would have checked this up
variations and and after that the match
went back to solid offensive black so it
was just a very brief period except I
think game nine he tried to play the
semi Slav against me because he was
behind in the match but this is what is
supposed to happen and nowadays very few
people will take the bait like that
they'll take it if they genuinely
believe that white is winning then you
know you you you can't hold back and
you'll go in for it but mostly people
will sidestep rather than charging
toward main lines when they expect that
you will have checked everything so
you'll always assume well I can see very
far but there's one move further my
opponent is gone and what's the point of
I can't afford to find this out in this
way so but it's true I mean I expected
occasionally some chances with white but
in this match has been completely barren
with white I mean today is almost
looking like the biggest day I just
posted I want to get it we want to get
into that in a second
Vichy but I do like a term you just use
where you use the term information
advantage explain that to us explain it
to our viewers and also what it means in
the context of a match okay so this is
no longer the case here but before the
second game Magnus has to prepare let's
say he wants to go d4 he's going to
prepare all of fab' strides he has to
revise the Queens gambit accepted he has
to revise the Greenfeld he has to buy
the Queens gambit declined apps there
are all sorts of other small lines that
he has to go over
so he spread very very thin whereas
Fabian on the other hand has to prepare
for several white moves but is generally
happy if say that he only has to revise
the Queens gambit declined and go over
all the lines you know all the sub
variations and so on so even though you
may be you may know the line and you may
even remember some details the line you
looked at most intensely intensively in
the morning is the one that you'll
remember the best and be completely
familiar with ins and outs and and that
is what you want to avoid the opposite
situation that you play something
against an opponent who is clearly
waiting for it and you have a little
little information as to which sub
variation is not at all so you don't
want your tenth line of the day to be
his top line in terms of that and I
think that's simply it now that doesn't
mean you don't never take a risk at the
board of course at the board you'll have
to take a call on which line you got a
call and which you you believe in your
position and your evaluation and you
going to chance it but in Game three
Vladdy I think made a big mistake
charging down this line because even if
he believed that he was better he should
have assumed that I would have had my
reasons for charging into it can you
tell us a little bit about the
atmosphere about the tournament in Tata
Tess India where she won the blitz
portion of and hopefully next year it
won't conflict with the world
championship of course it won't it was
very nice they it's the first tournament
in India where so many of the world's
top ten have been playing and the Indian
contingent was also very strong Kolkata
is it is a city where there are a lot of
chess fans and they turned out quite
well to watch so there was a fair amount
of buzz as well and I found the
atmosphere and I and the organization
very very pleasant I'm always somewhere
else
and so it was very nice to play at home
and I enjoyed that feeling a lot and I
hope I hope it'll happen again the other
really interesting thing was this year
our top juniors yeah a lambda any health
serene both got a chance to play in the
beginning I wasn't sure how it was going
how it is going to be for them because I
thought of course they should take this
opportunity but the tournament could
easily go horribly wrong I mean you
start with a couple of defeats and then
you might not even be able to stop I
mean we've seen this even with
experienced players in some of the
rapids and blitz events that you just
not able to stop but in fact both of
them are very mature about it they if
they took if they took some blows they
punched back and they were very sensible
about it
so both Nahal who managed to keep the
damage 2-3 and only with black and
program on the who one of you again so
in blitz it's harder to control the
stuff but he won a few games so both of
them were nice as well I hope that will
happen it's it's nice that out of steel
isn't organizing a tournament only in
the Netherlands yeah this she could we
could we take a look at this game
position which Fabi has been sitting on
for quite some time after the moves
Bishop e2 and Bishop to g5 that Magnus
has played avoiding maybe the major
stuff but curious to know you had you
said about this position you feel that
Magnus says his kind of position maybe
even a slight edge could you give us
some of the nuances that you see in this
position well off the top of my head
what I would like to do with black is to
play a c4 and 95 kick the bishop and
when the bishop moves get in Bishop d7
c6 the bishop on b6 is definitely an
awkward piece yeah white could sometimes
kick get an idea for c5 and so on but
basically I don't yet see how black can
free himself White's got just a little
bit of Unknowing pressure with the pin I
guess I would play D c4 in the head 6
but maybe fabbi is looking at something
more concrete d4
is playable but there's 94 when black in
considered e3 and you get these if takes
well actually that's the problem or is
that if you play hit six I might be able
to take on f6 here so black might have
to play d4 or DC for before hit six you
made your point made he did take on c4
immediately that move just came in so T
takes c4 as your instincts suggested yes
d4 was interesting as well because if
you get that Bishop to b4 sometimes it's
nice the problem again is that he's not
it's not easy for him to play e5 because
always night if I was landing I mean if
I landed in this position unprepared I
would say that black is slightly was but
I don't know and I assume that they have
some dots here
so with that meanings with further but
more concrete yeah with that move DC for
on the board what
when you say slightly worse how do you
feel about whites winning chances here
you feel it's a it's just a little bit
annoying or you or you feel like it's
enduring like this this is something
you'd feel like you might have to suffer
yeah I think it I think black will have
to be more careful at the moves then
white and whites gonna get some pieces
to some nice squares and blacks don't
have to work a bit that's what I mean by
slightly better in this position it
shouldn't be that bad I mean blacks the
bone structure is symmetrical so I don't
see being a huge problem so DC for
Bishop takes c4 maybe Knight a5 is a
possibility and just get rid of some
pieces that frees up the c6 square for
the bishop on c8 income d7 c6 for
instance or DC for Bishop c4 Bishop c7
with the area Bishop e5 is another idea
a little bit of space
it's much harder for black to mow busy
pond so just a little bit unpleasant I
think when you said that they might have
some ideas here did you mean this exact
position or you just mean they looked at
so many different wrinkles similar to
this that black is really well-prepared
for this potentially slight disadvantage
I know I mean I meant that if they had
looked at this line they might just know
a certain solution something like DC 495
head 696 you know some specific line
that they're trying to remember and
which gets very close to equality
something like that right so exact so
when you heard when you heard that
obviously Fabi
was going to be the Challenger when you
saw that Bobby was gonna be the
Challenger how did your thoughts on his
chances in the match changed from when
he won the candidates in Berlin to move
one to right now have you kind of felt
the odds are about the same or if it
hasn't shifted a lot I mean I kept
putting Magnus's as favorite by but but
not by very much so I think the the
preferred number these days is fifty
five forty five people not wanting too
far out what struck me was that Fabio's
results against I mean Fabio results
have exploded this year
I mean his rating performance is very
high and Magnus's is by his own and
relative standards of course not been
very comfortable that's one thing taking
account but I kept on seeing that their
games against each other are still very
much like one way traffic
Magnus puts a lot of pressure as white
and he won in Norway yeah he won in
Norway he won in I saw him win in Isle
of Man last year and that was a game
where Fabi came up with the big novelty
was putting a lot of pressure and Magnus
was able to counter-attack and win and
it's been quite a while since Robbie has
put any sort of pressure on Magnus
in fact yesterday's game was the first
time that was frost
so it looked like Magnus was still very
uncomfortable opponent for fabbi and
that was influencing my thoughts after
six games I think and it's also very
important for Magnus to have this
feeling that he's come safe he and I
think that's also one reason why he will
often head for end games rather than
complicated technical wins because he
likes this feeling of being absolutely
invincible now we all do the point is in
dry endings he'll often take a small
advantage in a dry ending rather than
something where he still has to
calculate and work but there's counter
play a song and I think he needs to feel
this invulnerability to play freely but
I think after yesterday is he
understands that he can lose as well
because yesterday he was outplayed and
sorry day before he was outplayed and
came close to losing so if a bee can
scare him once or twice then it's of
course 5050 but the games as well I mean
if White's like this it doesn't matter
who's who is what if white is struggling
like this to show anything then it's
going to be die break but of course both
of them will continue to play at a high
level and but I think we're getting to
the point where one mistake will decide
the match because there's very little
recovery time left so I mean we must
remember how unlikely it was that
Carlson came back against Kuryakin and
karaoke night at least two four straws
in that game before Carlson was able to
win it and this match looks even tighter
so because Magnus was creating a lot of
chances in that match here he's it's
been game one and then both sides have
enjoyed playing black so a very very
tight match but the price of each era is
very high now and this middle ground was
with dc4 having been played after much
thought Magnus also stopping to look at
the board obviously Knight d2 and as
possible I have it here on the board as
Knight d2 but only DC force been played
the Bishop c4
you mentioned the tiebreak
are you as certain it looks as many
people are that Magnus is the
prohibitive favorite by far if it gets
to tiebreak and if that is the case how
does that impact his play in the rest of
this match the classic Norman no he's
not favorite at all
he's I would let me put it this way if
we go if we're talking of if the
tiebreak was how Magnus and fabbi will
play in the next four or five in blitz
events no competition but in in a
tie-break against each other with the
stakes as high as they are I think
nerves are much more important than past
ourselves I mean we're not talking abou
the better rapido blitz player we're
talking a [ __ ] win the tiebreak with
the with all the nervous pressure
they're going to be under and it's also
got that Faby someone who's got wild
swings in rapid and blitz he can finish
last but he can also finish 3rd like he
did in st. Louis so he's got some
variance and he can play very well as
well so I don't think Magnus is a
favorite because again rapid and blitz
seem to come more easier to him then
fabbi but the advantage isn't that big
because I feel the match the tension and
the pressure is more important as a
factor than rapid inlet skills that's
that's really interesting and you had a
rapid in blitz tiebreak yourself or one
of your World Championship matches live
against Gelfand what was that like very
similar I well I was my rapid in Berlin
to the Sullivan Courier are quite a bit
higher than elephants but it was very
very close game to well I pulled off but
there's nothing inevitable about it game
3 I was busted and Game four I could
easily have lost as well and I have the
feeling that when when you're not
thinking clearly then rapid scales are
not that important
and it's more important just to play the
best moves you can under the pressure
and still that's something that comes
easier for Magnus but I wouldn't say
that he's a huge favorite in there
Abaddon Bloods I love it
you're the first person to say that
Vichy and I was trying to say something
similar at dinner last night but indeed
it's just so wonderful to hear you say
that
because of course here in st. Louis were
on Team Bobby yeah it doesn't the very
authoritative voice he's done that
before once or twice once it twice this
XI if I could just test your little gut
instinct for a moment we're looking at
this current position and Marissa and I
on our break had looked at the moves 90
to 95 night on C to e4 Bishop d7 castles
Bishop c6 Knight takes f6 G takes f6 we
got to a position like this where black
was a pawn up but his King side was a
little compromised and I thought well
black is doing ok but you know yourself
what it's like to have a compromised
King
what's your need your instinctive
reaction if I were to show you this
position would you say I prefer black or
I'd like to gamble with white I think
like is fine here because there's almost
no way to exploit that weakness and on
top of that the black knight on e5 can
go to g6 if need be in fact if you go
back a move or two if we just step back
a second yeah did he play Bishop d7 yeah
there's also Bishop a5 and if castles
you could play b5 maybe because yeah the
King sighting is quite safe for black
it's very far from delivering a mate or
something so here I might even want to
try and
the pond I don't know it's I would have
to look at the idea but it occurred to
me but I think that position that we you
had a bit later with Bishop d7 c6 and so
on
I've had this dozens of times of - well
it's very typical of this V n QT d
structure that you might get these and
especially the VN now because you can
get this pond from G's g7 on f6
but unless white is able to swing
something over to the Kings side a major
piece I it's just not good for black in
that case yes yeah I mean I think equal
rather than anything else yeah but that
was my feeling too and you you said it
very well yourself in a Vienna you're
often getting these double pawns and
sometimes you're not even afraid of
losing in exchange because you've got
these bishops that are doing very well
overall does anything what has been the
biggest surprise for you about the match
so far does she or has anything really
surprised you six draws out of six games
I would say it's been striking that
white has looked so helpless I I didn't
expect that I mean you expect Y to be
neutralized but this is absurd and
otherwise I can't say I'm really
surprised
I expected a tough match with tough play
and it seems to be developing like that
are you surprised
are you surprised as this thought that
I'm bit shocked out when I hear this
number that in 18 games in the World
Championship the counting this one and
the 12 he played against car yeah keen
that Magnus is only won one game if you
put it like that I didn't expect a lot
of decisive games in this match I
thought we were looking at two or three
maximum and now I'm not even sure we win
if there's
one decisive game I think the odds of
two are already looking very low simply
because they have not managed to create
anything so fast I don't know where it's
gonna appear from so if we revise that
statistic after game 12 it'll be 1 in 24
or something like that is Magnus as
dominant as it used to be he said that
his favorite player he joked in a press
conference his favorite player of all
time is himself from 3 or 4 years ago is
he that dominant still I know in our
minds the mystique remains but how did
the players feel about it and with all
those players now like Fabien my Madeira
of and ding Lauren who closed the gap to
now just a hair's breadth is is it still
the perception of everyone that Magnus
is a dominant player or easy now first
potentially among equals I classify
anyway yes I I think very much the gap
is closed and it's closed not completely
but you know it's it's a very small
difference now of course there's a lag
because when some somebody was that
dominant when you play them you you tend
to be careful anyway big or you know
motivate yourself to be extra precise
because he's done that stuff so many
times and it sticks in your memory but
his results have definitely tapered off
especially what's striking is the number
of winning positions he doesn't convert
I mean this is managed to convert equal
positions with the percentage then and
he's missing quite some big ones it's
it's still impressive that he creates so
many winning chances but the Magnus from
3 to 4 years ago would have one of you
so I what's your generation for that how
is that possible he he says he knows a
lot better chestnut a lot more chest now
he studies a lot more he studies he's
added more to his repertoire he knows
more things and yet he's not getting
those results
my own feeling is the other players have
gotten better so the other players
through being forced to play Magnus
again and again over the last four or
five years have gotten slightly better
at playing him their own defensive
skills have improved many of the
positions Magnus used to specialize in
now many of them dabble in so I feel
that well we all learned from each other
even when we don't realize it and I
think the other players have definitely
at some level absorbed some of the
lessons from Magnus well you know you
really want to thank you for joining us
but I just want to ask you one more
question Vichy what do you want to see
happen in this match are you rooting for
a tie-break are you reading for Fabi to
win one Magnus to win one or what would
you like to see happen in these last six
games well it'd be nice to have a
decisive game I simply do be nice to
have a well-played game and tiebreaks
fine as well so both options are I mean
I like both these guys I'm not going to
prefer one over the other but if the
match was decided in a great game that
would be perfect otherwise it'll be
deciding tiebreaker that's perfectly
well is as well thank you very I want to
say you're you're wonderful guest and
anytime you want to come on the show
maybe even you know take my place come
and take a seat you're more than welcome
thank you so much for joining us thanks
fishy
thanks right yes awesome thank you so
much five-time world champion
viviana yeah I mean he just
I love how obviously such a genius but
also so down-to-earth and it seems like
his opinions are all kind of based on
fact an observation rather than personal
bias but also it feels that this was a
kind of a timeless quality why are you
looking at so closely like
like you know actually Rex has this
great line somebody asked him a question
and he just kind of looks at the
question and he says I'm just so
impressed that you think I have the
answer good about that no I felt that
there was an authoritative voice with
this she you know he's been there he
knows what he's talking about
would you like a second oh you kidding
me boy get over here and sit out I'm not
letting you escape and actually that was
a question I wanted to ask him but I
really didn't want to put him on a spot
which was did either camp approach him
and say Vichy would you like to work
with me or would you please work with me
but I felt just a little bit
uncomfortable asking him that question
well one day perhaps with Anna and I and
surion right I think would be really
great about having Eva she is the second
it would be like can you imagine if you
lost a game you know going to Vichy I
don't think he'd be that upset he'd be
like okay what do we do we have to
rationally figure out what to do to
attack the next game exactly yeah no no
I I just have the feeling that he would
be the guy that would just be
encouraging always encouraging and he
would have that data he'd say oh yeah
you know we're gonna get him the next
game right like this is how Magnus beat
me game 2 of our imagine I made him a
game three let's go and he could line it
up yell fun beat me and I and I beat him
back and he could go game I beat Apollo
I beat him in Game one right of their
match and then he smoked them right so
he'd have a data after data just
throwing at you by the time he's done
you'd think oh it was good for me to
lose I wouldn't worry about that for
mine I got him where I want to Maurice
both players have slowed down really
consider oh yeah break on this one they
were just going very very smoothly
through those 92-93 Queen a5 moves but
now we're talking
ten and fifteen minute things we see 95
on the board has not been played we have
it but there was a long thing over d5
take c4 I'm really not longest think of
the game I'm really not too sure what
the alternative was because this move
looks so compelling
I think overnight d2 and now we haven't
we've been expecting 95 for some time
but we haven't seen that is that correct
we're still waiting for a fab you to
play them correctly and actually we're
looking at the SSE the Norwegian
supercomputer yes it's recommending I'll
bring that up on my screen it's
recommending the move 86 as a subtle
nuance first the point being that the
mission pointing back to h4 exposes it
to a night attack so this move here
potentially the move night g6 will land
and chase this Bishop away from this pin
run that is the move it is recommending
in this position after Knight to d2 and
both ways as you said these last couple
of moves seem as if they're super
critical in their minds exactly the
trend line of this game you don't want
the advantage if you're white to just
slip away and black equalizes without
any trouble so you've got to look inside
all those nuances as you look at every
single possibility that black to do
before developing those pieces because
obviously black wants to bring the
bishop out and get the rooks in that's
that's gonna be that's what it was
that's clear no question about it how do
you prevent that you're gonna have to
waste the tempo I say waste castles
normally is a good move getting your
King away to safety and we're gonna
trigger to the game but essentially it's
it's a bit of a waste of a tempo because
it means black gets a free move it
doesn't threaten anything does castles
so white is gonna play to make sure that
he gets a little something and how can
he do so with all this a little bit of
tension and the main tension is this
diagonal but I I just think that point
about this pin not being that serious
along this line it's a really important
feature in this position that's probably
super important in regulation because if
this pin is not that serious
then all black acid was get his pieces
in the game although this [ __ ] did point
out watch out for this Bishop on b6 it
now has been sulphide by the pawn
structure in 493 there's no deep
or anymore so that could be a bit of a
point for black as well to try to
harmonize his pieces well this was the I
mean because the players of taking so
much time this is actually the variation
that Jennifer and I actually looked at
and Jennifer's idea of h6 Bishop h4 was
just precisely as you said to then play
Knight e5 and to bring the knight back
to g6 to break this pin we had something
Jen wasn't it light but it was like the
same concept yeah absolutely no question
so just I
I'm guessing h6 precision position after
95 and I played 96
you mean right back here I took it once
no no yeah maybe in 85 and then you are
breaking the pin we're showing how when
you get your rook to do you while
there's still some nagging pressure for
white right that I prefer white that's
what you said yeah fair enough
I mean that looks right laughter of one
hour ago yeah exactly might be too
we're expecting aged six the assessee
supercomputer nuance variation Knight e5
and let's say castles but I like what
what Maurice was saying that if this pin
is not scaring you and you can just play
Bishop d7 Bishop to c6 and bring your
rooks into the game how was whites
opposed to getting an advantage that was
why I wasn't a hundred percent sure
about the oops excuse me castle
well no I wasn't a hundred percent sure
about the move h7 h6 because in one of
the variations I was looking at with
Vichy we we got a position like this
right
last time my bishop was on g5 here I can
take take and at least my I don't lose a
tempo my bishop was on g5 after 57 806
okay 694 right away so I wasn't sure
about whether I should Castle or play 94
right away but if you okay so even 94
right away okay yeah sure let's do it
let's take them now with 57 well this is
where Vichy also proposed a Bishop a5 b5
kind of idea but Bishop d7 sure you know
Knight of 6 and 94 Knight f6 and 94
right that's already know that is really
scary oh yeah this move order doesn't
quaint because again last time my bishop
was on g5 and I didn't have the
possibility of 94 right so with with h6
tossed in it does change the the setup a
little bit yes that means that after 94
you have to try one of these other
runners well breaking news guys let's
just make sure well sure eight-six did
not get played nice he was not played at
all 95 was played and stay immediately
immediately and then castles and now
we're up to date with the position okay
so the player and this is where I think
we were Mauricio and I were on our break
some time ago looking at Bishop d7 as
the main line is that still horse yeah
just get worse that's what you want to
do you want to get your pieces into the
game and there's absolutely natural here
the angels are giving basically equal
position after Bishop to d7 will there
be something else that Magnus does to
liven end live in this game with that 90
for assessing that the pin on f6 is an
issue but the bishop was coming to c6
really fast so he'll have to deal with
that well but okay hold on Maurice just
a second you know me I'm a pawn grubber
I'm a pawn down I'm not a happy camper
and when Magnus played the move Knight
d2 his intent was to recapture
this pawn ASAP shouldn't he be doing
that I mean this she basically suggested
that the whole concept of Knights e3 e4
sacrificing a pom was not serious and
that the second player isn't worried
about that that being the case shouldn't
Magnus be winning his pawn back on c4
and trying for something in those
positions well it looks as though the
position would be very tricky they play
out play out that position like for a
moment when I take c4 how would it go
tonight takes e4 Bishop takes e4 right
you would hit me with a rook c8 I
presume and this this is or even h6
first and force your Bishop to move
unless you're gonna trade off no I'm not
gonna trade up right we'd like so now
this move and CA and as you're looking
at this position the I guess the pin on
the the diagonal is still there although
can always be somewhat resolved with the
move g5 but that's gonna be okay it's a
radical solution but it is a potential
solution yes the other thing is the
other thing is you have this pin on the
C line as well to deal with right with
Bishop a4 Bishop a5 that is being
possible in some positions so for
example if I drop back this move could
be kind of harassing right well you get
to play before but now your knight is
loosened so your queen will have to move
at some point then Queen B - looks like
a decent oh you're coming to be five
well again this was a Vishy Anand yeah
what he was mentioning that this Bishop
on b6 I don't have time for 94 because
one of the two is this Bishop on b6 does
bite on granite this pawn on e3 and f2
really kills that diagonal but that was
why this she was looking at get out of
that pain instead of Bishop e2 very good
yeah that's what I was thinking - yeah
because now if Bishop a5 we still have
the 94 so you can't that that that's no
good anymore well it's again it's like
still
you're right we have to look at this
exactly you know these are our knee-jerk
reaction is that the we you know we
induced a weakness we created a weakness
but they're not weak if we can't attack
them and blacks got some mighty pieces
here I mean that work already being
developed the bishop coming to cease
it's very very useful all right it's not
it's not convinced I'm not convinced
that Magnus has something special in the
tank and it looks like we do have to
move Bishop d7 and we're gonna take a
quick break as we see how this this
Queen and their middlegame
we don't have an endgame this time guys
and it's rich right back with more
analysis absolutely
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with a
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess halls
of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the World Chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to today macaws
World Championship Edition where we are
still deadlocked at three points for
Magnus Carlsen the reigning world champ
and three points for Fabiano Khurana the
American challenger haling from st.
Louis the match being held in London we
have around seven underway I think the
first game so far in the match that
we've been into the two-hour mark with
Queen still on the board yes oh hello
ladies
the Women's World Championship is not
being held today it's the only rested
but there are finally we've been
sticking around on the board a little
longer we have a much richer middle game
than we've been treated to so far in the
match and although and games haven't
left us complaining no they've been
quite exciting but this position is
really neutralized no no seriously even
though there's green still on the board
all the crazy variations baseships and
g5 are out the window right there's no
more pin against this knight on f6 and
the Queen us and e7 and our this in
other words this Bishop bought on g3 has
been chased away from the diagonal
there's no pin no in no pin the win yeah
no pain no gain and these two bishops
again c7 and c6 bishops are really fine
the chopping block is on the d5 chopping
has commenced by the way has it really I
believe there's been 95 no sorry um
we're taking we're pigs do you wanted
what takes d1 have occurred and then
worked da okay so we just had rook da de
and then there was a move for white on
da a white plate would be one I believe
exactly rook takes the rook takes the
rook e1 so there's been a trader Brooks
are ready on the chopping block and
another one in sight and talk about dead
dead or ninety five to trade off some of
the miners or night yeah I just see
other of a pair of rocks I see a lot of
child
in the near future as pieces are going
to be Hoover it off the board and if you
look at the structure four versus four
on the center kingside two versus two on
the queenside there's just no advantage
in this position and I can imagine that
black once again has completely
neutralized White's opening advantage
there's there's no vestige whatsoever of
an opening advantage that I can see so
equal equal equal Maurice how equal do
you want it the word that jumped in my
mind was a word imbalance imbalance
imbalance in chess as needed in order to
create some kind of options
possibilities in tension I looked up the
word I wanted the exact definition went
to the Google dictionary to find this
word imbalance and I get the definition
lack of proportion or relation between
corresponding things in chess a lot more
for lack of relation between
corresponding things those corresponding
things being the chess pieces that we
each have on the board I don't have a
bishop and you have a knight no we have
two bishops two nice two rooks we start
with that but until you create an
imbalance usually you have nothing
whether it's pawn structure whether it's
difference in minor pieces Bishop versus
Knight it could be a difference of queen
versus two rooks it could be that I have
a weak poem but you have an exposed King
some kind of imbalance is needed in
order to talk about them being tension
in position and the example they give
here a work way to use imbalance tension
is generated by the imbalance of power
tension is generated by the imbalance of
power the word tension is the key going
back to this position where is the
tension where am I worried I don't feel
tense I don't feel danger if I'm black I
don't feel that way either as white we
have total symmetry pawns are
symmetrical pieces Knights look fine
bishops are in good diagonals rooks on
the open file where's the tension
where's the imbalance it does not exist
in this position this one is it
triple zero equal for sure what will
happen in the next 13 moves or so
well we're ten more moves I'm sure if
this was a regular casual
no rules associated with it you would be
set you'd be looking at a draw the
players would say this this is nothing
I'm not gonna beat you here but they
have to make the next ten moves and
we've seen some times you can make some
moves and some float a little bit and
something bad happens
but this one no imbalances absolutely
equal position all right
well Jennifer that well if we follow up
with what Marissa says is true that
would mean our seven consecutive draw
now you and I were last night at a gala
where we were talking about this and
you'd ask me well what's the possibility
of 12 consecutive draws and I said no no
mathematically I don't see that
happening I think there's going to be a
decisive game or two oh sure there's
more likely that there will be a
decisive game precise with every passing
draw starting the exact same right I
mean starting to match it's obviously
very unlikely but now that we're in
round seven in if this game doesn t be a
draw don't forget we almost tried to
call yesterday very early that it was
probably gonna be a draw in it and there
was hours of richness ahead of us but as
Marie says this one is less imbalanced
that said what the way you do it is you
you give yourself a nod of each draw of
each game being a draw and then you just
keep multiplying that by itself yeah so
I'm pretty certain you you you get to a
near certainty of a decisive game by now
at the 12th game I don't think so it
depends what number you use if you use
something like point eight you just have
point eight times times 0.8 that's six
for another one is 0.5 are already at
three and then I said we're at three
right at point five and that then we're
gonna be at point yeah we're gonna be
like 25 25 to 30 percent and it's but
point eight some people might say eighty
percent is like a really high draw rate
that it's actually more like 70 percent
we're just biased because of the
direction of the match so far yeah so
that's the question what number do you
use there that actually changes things
like more than you might expect if you
if you swap a a seven for the eight
you're gonna be looking at way lower
odds given oh well blacks been doing
yeah
tonight I think it's even more likely
that they're gonna draw they're not as
nothing has happened with against the
black pieces so far and without any
attention for black without any real
difficulties black has been on cruise
control pretty much this whole match
and everybody's stunned by it but as I
made that great point I love the point
he made where he said that white has to
prepare what does he call it information
disadvantage or information granted
white doesn't know what black is going
to play and white doesn't know which sub
variations binds in a play so you got a
search in search and search fine to find
out what's going on what's going and you
take a while to get there
we saw seven straight matte seven state
drawers to begin the match last time
kuryakin versus Carlson seven straight
drugs before Magnuson lost in game eight
and game eight has been a particularly
boisterous rambunctious battle
belligerent might be the right word hand
but Brown round eight of all the twelve
game met the twelve game World
Championships of which they've been
seven brown eight has seen for decisive
games for that's a that's the most
you'll see and then you go back into
World Championship matches
oddly game eight has been particularly
belligerent in its result in its game
and also in its result decisive games I
don't know what the deal with the number
eight but you'll see that is the case if
you look at all the World Championships
and I'm going all the way back to Stein
itsuka toward so this one looking like a
tepid draw still a lot to go but
potentially game eight tomorrow could be
decisive now the record though has been
eight straight games to begin a World
Championship match that happened in 1995
when Anant and Kasparov played their
match in New York City in fact in the
World Trade Center but an on one game
nine only get punched in the face in
game ten drawing eleven lose twelve and
then the dominoes foul as Kasparov just
kept winning game after game and ran
away with the match that dragon really
turned it around but it was that game
ten epic game ten in the real Lopez that
we all remember the amazing
calculate mazing preparation that is
that Kasparov did in that game and he
said he was so excited about playing his
new preparation that he ignored game 9
he said game 9 he's like you can't even
think about it because he couldn't wait
to have white again and then he got
mauled in game 9 but when he got white
that was the famous door banging game
where right where I nan said cuz bar
would make a move get up walk out of the
playing area and would swing the door
shut I don't think I did it on purpose
but it would make a banging sound and
then Garry would come back in and
instantly make a move every single time
poor unknown was there looking at this
big preparation and Gary's make him walk
out and boom the door would bang again
is it to say I'm banging your head
against the wall right now and he just
crushed him so game 10 you want to look
at that match spectacular game but so so
that means you can't see a lot of
drawers to begin to match folks it's not
that infrequent that it happens that was
the open Spanish okay you're my top math
agent here Jennifer what's your
prediction are we gonna see 12 draws in
a row
yes or no it's definitely I think it's
definitely less likely I think it's more
likely as vichy says that there will be
one decisive games but with every
passing draw it's more and more likely
duh sorry to take the obvious but last
night I was saying something like 20 to
25% if this game is a draw it goes up to
like 30 percent 30 30 30 percent and
then so on and so on right and it keeps
going up as as we approach each beam yes
exactly yeah and especially I think the
last couple rounds and might actually
see even bigger spike if Magnus liked it
like he did against Carr yakun thus
inclined well here's my stick to with
that is that with each progressive draw
the tension gets ramped up and the risk
factor becomes so great that neither
player wants to take too big a risk and
disturb the equilibrium got to
eventually well it may happen only if we
get to a rapid in the meantime we did
have a second trade of rooks after rook
d1 we have seen the movie uptakes d8 by
fabbi Queen takes d1
okay so a lot of material
ten points worth of material just left
the board the chopping block on the D
file has done its bit and now we see
this move that you had mentioned
Jennifer Knight f6 to d5 by fabbi
engaging or simply offering a further
trade of knights with this move Knight
d5 and the cleaning ladies at work just
who bring the pieces off the board yeah
they hired her was doing good this
actually doesn't feel like a human
cleaning it feels like you know they
hide one of those go BOTS or on the
floor has been doing work yeah clean
place looks crystal clean cuz ain't no
kind of danger or dirt in this position
at all I mean this one you'd feel like
you could draw anybody anytime even an
engine you wouldn't be scared of if you
had either color in this position
remember gristick said that he would
lose with either color last game he
would lose with either color against the
supercomputer I wonder what his opinion
is of this one this one is just so dead
the green [ __ ] quotes from chess 24
apparently uses he liked this ski better
because it was either gonna get really
exciting you know yeah two days ago was
like reading a book and getting to the
interesting part on page 13 hundred out
of 3,000 to read the book where do we
see this one adding Snoozeville snooze
Ville I mean even if he if someone were
to be able to pull this one off I will
tell you the other guy might commit
suicide I mean how did I lose write this
position no way in the world you should
lose this I would say I'm ninety-nine
out of a hundred nineteen 999
yeah me come on what you come on dude we
need four by the way was played right
but you're absolutely right but think
about that game six it was an exchange
French for crying out loud that was like
his drawn is drunk complete x-ray Branch
formation yeah then came c6 c5 which you
know fab he was trying to mix it up but
you would never thought in a million
years that either player was gonna get
anything decisive and it nearly happened
but that said yes this is a game yeah
you got a little pawn energy in that
game there yes I did ramped up the
energy the one that's a pawn break for
black that we thought was inferior
though structurally but dynamically was
really good for black and I'll show that
when Magnus made a couple of tepid moves
Bishop c2 he criticized himself said he
just thought he could just relax and do
nothing and they found out that black
actually had quite a bit of play there
so that was because you had a nice pawn
break show me the pawn break please
I want a little energy to play for that
you push the e pawn on the board it
doesn't break with anybody you could try
to throw the H pawn that's not gonna do
anything no B 5 to play beef I mean
where's the pawn break and if you don't
have a Padre then show me the bad pieces
that one side has Shelby just one bad
piece I'm thinking say oh this night or
this night is terrible
okay right now we might argue this night
is is bad but the bishop on c6 is
probably the best piece kind of balances
it out no but but see I was actually
being facetious it's perfectly fine they
can always dance back into the game yet
as a future in the game somewhere so
that Knight is not going to be something
you play against I mean will Magnus go
for something like h4 at some point to
chase the night himself no thing so no
can do you have to trade here first and
if a g3 then he had to play for this
idea yeah he could by the way if he
pushes this and pushes g3 guess who
wakes up that Bishop on c6 is also in
wait and wait let's do that Maggie yeah
I like that I got the guy is the guy
wants to win gays but he ain't stupid
this one here
he's very aware the only there's only
one way you lose this game
well okay let me say that chess is a
game you can lose many ways sure
black would have to start doing some
crazy things you'd have to little
weaknesses here and there get you
excited make you play and white would
have to also and it's not just a little
crazy there'll be a lot and I think
you're not they induce it out of him
this would be some subtle inducements I
mean you've got a you got a had a cookie
on this side a little cupcake on the
other come on man just just do something
right in your position a little bit you
know it's dead equal you could do
anything you wanted to just do it
already don't you want to win yeah I
think as far as bobbies concerned draw
go home you have three whites even
though white has been anemic this whole
match right still you have three whites
and two blocks to go draw is exactly
what the doctor ordered and your I can
tell you his seconds we'll be thinking
yeah boy oh that was nice that
preparation worked out perfectly
yeah and that means also I mean what do
you think about this guy's Magnus's
preparation has meant nothing with the
white pieces you know he's not he can't
look forward to having white those two
games is he looking forward I'm gonna
make that thing it that question to you
is he looking forward to his next two
whites given how anemic white has been
for him this whole man well the question
is would you rather have white and black
I know we're looking at the entire
history of chess as opposed no we're not
no no I'm sorry the entire three of
their careers the history of chess is
right now but I mean no I don't think
you can I don't think you can throw away
the event at the white house that's like
you know saying you showed up to an
interview late you killed it
you know you got the job therefore it
was good to come show up late
no it's no if your sample size is one
interview okay we got seven games to
show us from this match to use history
we've used history quite a bit and we're
always going to use history and we're
inclined that way but but this
match has shown something and you could
I'm not gonna just go on the side of
history if this match is telling me
something else so whether or not he
prefers to have white well we we are we
would have answered that question yes no
matter what almost right no matter what
so let's not be let's recognize our own
bias but in this match it has been shown
that why he's not doing anything because
blacks defenses have been so good does
it make sense to really give white all
that credence that credibility of having
the advantage as this match has not
shown that at all definitely last but I
still think that Magnus and Carolina's
teams would likely player to have black
and white no no no they're not but this
she did use a very intriguing word to
describe whites play in this match and
he said Darren Darren
that is to say white has not been coming
up with ideas to put pressure on his
opponent and this game is typical why
because in those critical challenges
after the move Bishop e6 out of fear of
preparation or whatever Magnus is not
castling is not playing the move rook d1
is not playing the move Bishop g5 he's
playing the tap of choice Bishop e2 and
this constant hesitant play has fretted
away and he advantages that white has
had and we're seeing it again in this
game a barren outlook for white and I'm
intrigued to see if anybody can make
anything with white in the remaining
games I'm all in balance small in
balance we got an imbalance big news big
break breaking news well three on the
board a double bond look at the Abu
pause and an all sonís weakness week was
10th potential but at least is an
imbalance of the pawn structure on the
Kings side is no longer symmetrical so
that is something super super slight who
does it favor in this position white
could say you have that's not a real
weakness stop it
more well there's no no more h4 h5 ideas
folks correct and after the points in
which we do see there on the board
high seven was but black is prepared to
move a night now eventually to the e7
square and look for greener pastures on
f5 or potentially d5 or even c6
depending on how that Bishop handling so
you don't want to let 895 happen right
right so your timing has to be really
good there but he'll play move even
there it might be necessary for white
for black to play a move like f6
eventually to play F sake so that he can
keep a night out of the square e 5 and
then start the path of his Knight well
in the middle here's an intriguing
question I thought that if I'm black I
really like the idea of Queen to c5 so
that I could go Queen to d5 and threaten
checkmate
hip-hip-hooray right got a threaten
checkmate Queen c5 to d5 would have been
my chosen path in the game Fabiano has
played the move Queen d7 also eyeballing
the d5 opportunity to play Queen d5
which in your view was more accurate or
how did the supercomputer a think of it
was Queen d7 the best move line before
is immediate tempo your Queen threat
doesn't do anything it does threaten
mate okay and after Bishop f3 defended
oh I'm sorry
hold on sorry I think I got the wrong
position for you Maurice Queen c5 you're
saying b4 yeah before what is your
thread mo before just asking me to go
for it okay what does we do 3 you should
pass through yang you just ended up
behind you induced the before yeah look
at that we can he move that incredible
blunderstone so objective over seven so
again I'm seeing the position as triple
zeros supercomputer see it exactly that
same way to Maurice nothing is going on
despite the double pawns okay suppose
you're watching a game with two I mean
yeah you coach at the tables just clubs
sometimes absolutely couple of Class A
Class B players I have to say maybe I'd
go for white like maybe CB amateur
players because I see that I like that I
have the control over the back rank I
have my King already you've already got
love and I not saying something's gonna
fall for a bank right just me I mean I
got to respect the class people they
know that I'm just saying like the e5
square it does seem like okay if it was
these are the best players in the world
so that's a different story but for
those of you watching that doesn't mean
we're saying you should just agree to a
draw here I feel like white has a
greater practical chances at the amateur
level oh no question and I have always
encouraged players not to offer draws
but just to play it out yeah and you
know learn how to play the positions
so my first minute centering your work
with with amateur players and you're at
the club right so we can talk about
really really really balanced positions
and there's really really dead positions
but then just as you're saying Jennifer
well maybe maybe you just have a slight
prejudice for one side or another easier
to play easier to play and I think I
would agree with you wholeheartedly that
amateur players by and large would
prefer white a little bit because
they're happy that they have the lift
that this night on c4 is ever so
slightly more active than the night on
g6 and maybe even looking way way way
ahead they would see a situation where
there was a trade of light squared
bishop x' and maybe they could put their
king in this beautiful cat cocoon
of protecting pawns and so I could
easily understand why many amateur
players would have a smidge of a favor
to it favoritism favoritism towards and
Maggie
Magnus did play Bishop to d3 in the
position we're looking at after Queen
did he said he's chosen Bishop David
three so so what does he got in behind
here at Bishop takes d6 and 85 but
there's a queen d1 check lingering I
can't imagine he has that in mind it's
clean keeping keeping the bishop pair be
good you know in my mind I thought of
Queen d5 as a threat because I thought
this Bishop on c6 was really good
bearing down on g2 when Magnus played
the move Bishop g3 I can only imagine
that in his mind he's thinking he will
play the movie 3 E 4 in the near future
to blunt that Bishop we had mentioned a
moment ago let's just put a move on the
board for a second something like f6 and
we're gonna put this move on the board
remember when we said well the knight
could redeploy so that it could go to
either the e5 or D Phi square so I could
imagine Magnus wants to put his bishop
on d3 to blunt the effectiveness of this
Bishop and maybe to make the move Knight
g6 East 7 less of a move it's not
changing the overall balance in my
opinion by the way there are some just
concrete draw lines in certain
situations where for instance in that
line that I was looking at with Bishop
d6 bond g6 and 95 ok so I need to move
so ok so like I'll make a move and what
were you saying about Bishop g6 I'm just
saying that after Bishop d6 pawns you
695 yes in some of these types of
variations don't forget there's always
just a simple queen d1 check you know
and then torpedoing over to age 5 and so
we've got a draw by perpetual check yeah
on coming up if you don't feel like
playing something else right so just
between D 1 and h5 a very famous pattern
a perpetual check and that could come up
in other variations as well the same
Queen d1 h5 Perpetua
like funny enough they could suppose
black just plays Bishop before here it
should be for a boy I get away with it
like that oh my how funny is that so I
could just sacrifice a piece that's
funny that shows you the pattern it may
be a very good move we're just trying to
make the draw right rah or unison meant
the drop by the way Jennifer we have a
phone call I am a little worried about
my back rank though I may be I've got to
make sure I have this right you got 9f a
visit okay that's true yeah I can't get
mated with a knight on g6
welcome to the show we have a phone call
hi this is Frank Amanda Walker hi I have
a question on as far as opening
preparation goes do you feel it's more
important to play the most objectively
good move or do you should you play a
move that's going to cause your opponent
more problems even though I might be
slightly dubious Frank the question
really has multiple answers and it
really depends upon your playing
strength and I really want to put it
like that so when I was an amateur
player I love to play risky super risky
gambit plays like the wings gambit that
we saw earlier in this match that before
kind of move so against amateur players
I really liked mixing it up and
especially if I felt my opponent got
gets nervous when his King is being
attacked now however when you move up
the ranks towards masters and
international masters these guys
defensive skills are so good they're not
going to be intimidated just because
you've got a check or even two checks in
a row they're gonna work things out so
it really depends upon the skill level
set that we're discussing I like risky
gambit imply at the amateur levels that
at the highest level you're not going to
see that kind of play take place here
absolutely not but just break the moves
on the move now got played after Bishop
to d3
probably
be six visa these six in this position
seem like it not entirely necessary but
the only thing in this position that's
not defended is that a pawn right by
playing b6 it is not protected by the
Queen a six of course would put upon on
a light square not harmonious with his
Bishop but in this position before the
engines also give as correct this move
is perfectly fine with no tricks to be
had there are some little ninety five
possibility that you could play for
hoping for this nice little help move
Queen takes on e5 and now the bishop is
under attack and there's a little back
rank issue even that's not serious
no Bishop c6 is possible here to deal
with that threat but Bobby said there's
nothing happening let me play b6 right
is it possible that he's gonna induce
Magnus into a little bit of madness yeah
like Magnus is just so badly wants to
win that he does something that
compromises his position Magnus will
remember you know that I mean Magnus
doesn't have to do any of that and vichy
made that point about him being safe
right well remember in game eight of the
Sergei karyakin match Magnus did lose
with white by over pressing his hand and
ended up in a situation he needed to tie
the match which he did in game 10 we
have another move by the way after b 7e
b 6 b 6 and again magnet it seems Tommy
yeah played by Magnus though it seems to
me as soon as I saw this move by Magnus
Bishop d3 seemed to me it's clear that
he was playing for III efore and with
the move f2 f3 it further that thought
it's gonna play king f to e4 Knight e3
now the crazy part is that very recently
Fabiano has included the Queens gambit
accepted into his repertoire as black
and this is just a straight middle game
ending out of a Queens gambit accepted
that is so so common so it seems to me
that Fabiano is actually going to have a
lot of experience with these types of
structures and he's going to feel
himself very very come
right like I was mentioning earlier
about how for an amateur player this
might be a little awkward for for black
just because of this the smidgen of
extra pressure we have on like the dark
squares and the fact that the knight on
g6 still has to figure out how to get
back into the game right away 97 losses
to 95 right right it's been but it's the
kind of thing that you need to figure
out what to do against and we're told is
when we start to play chess don't move
you're a pawn it's been fine gold is of
course loves to say just tape it down
and glue it down to the board you don't
know when to make exceptions right one
of the things why is that so good well
exactly we'll take a look at this Knight
on c4 looking at this knight on c4 for
white we really like this night because
it's got ideas of potentially going to
e5 to a5 and into d6 now if we compare
blacks last moves for a second b7 b6
that cuts out one of your options no
more Knight a5 coming up and after the
move f3
well f7 to b7 Magma's quickly replied
with Bishop takes g6 changing the
character position imbalance we have an
imbalance in balance on the board
suddenly after this exchange is it good
though okay we're gonna keep our chess
objectivity even though we're reading
for a B so f g6 now one of the things
that HDC yeah not ft 6 one of the things
that we do use these guiding principles
and things a lot of amateurs will be
very familiar with the idea that a queen
and Knight are a better more cohesive
force than a Queen and Bishop
so we have this prejudice of the in
favor of a queen and night versus a
queen and bishop
it's a little bit overstated I mean many
many times the Queen and Bishop do
perfectly well against the Queen and
Knight
the reason why we like the Queen and
night combination is because the knight
can flip colors that's right and because
it's like the close-up the close-up
nosov the night with the Queen works
really well but probably the reason it's
overstated yes it's cuz it's kind of
like a cool prince of all and usually
the [ __ ] of the little better than
Knight you think data has shown that so
even if it's overstated the fact that
it's comparable to the bishop rather
than worse is worth noting yeah but it
really is that combination that the
Queen and Knight can sometimes attack a
dark square complex or a light square
complex whereas the Queen and Bishop are
going to attack the complex it's on
Mary's well very specific though in this
position the movie for was played evil
was played and black has an opportunity
to virtually force white to make a draw
in this game if black wants to go there
the move Queen c7 right that's right
hitting this pawn on g3 and also
preparing a little bit of energy on this
line move like b5 looking to chase this
Knight wreck the pawn structure of
whites compromise him even further and
the engines are saying now that white
should not even worry about this
position play Queen d2 given this and
make your draw get out of there nice and
safe yourself
yeah because Queen c7 Queen c7 hits the
pawn on g3 and and also the pin on the
file and says what you got you're not
improving your position in any way I
move like 95 in order to keep Queens on
in order to keep Knights on and keep the
fight going does compromise this this
pawn formation for this piece so playing
like this would be hyper risky for white
and that Bishop would start feeling a
little bit more comfortable although the
doesn't quite attack these things in
that you would have to get this King to
get into the position which is not that
easy given that you cannot play f6 at
the moment because if you keep on you
got to play G v f6 right you have to get
this move in and then get your move in
then bring your King and see what
happens the rest of me time White will
be bringing his King into the game as
well how do you like that position
there's that seems that seems
complicated actually I'm curious this
position here is this any fear at all
for white of getting in any danger
because his pawn structure is worse but
his King does get into the game really
fast and he controls all the dark
squares well play move remove if you
will though King f2 King f8 do you want
to play f6 now or f6 if you like sure
and now I need to go back okay I want to
find a square for my knight no before I
do anything
so at the point I could go I could go to
d6 what about here your king is not
going to rest comfortably on defunding
or that's true Bishop a6 Bishop e6 mmm
d6 doesn't look that appetizing no less
so yeah yes although I do I may be able
that planted on this square with F 45
the problem but it doesn't look at
Vantage yep the bishop f1 you know gets
right you get get you from behind might
be annoying yeah yeah it's a little too
ambitious well Bobby's sitting on this
position back on and he can he can force
matters you're saying with Queen c7 let
me just pose up here this is C 7 is a
very concrete absolutely that's that's
asking a big question and I think that
if you see this move Queen c7 Queen d2
White's not gonna lose this position but
can white play for anything looks like
the answer is no another way to play
though is like this Queen d4 takes right
and then wait this is prepared Oh
so let's guard this square force you to
move and then what about this line
right now if you check I can just go
here and you don't have this check
no and and pawn is hanging with little
mate threats but f6 perhaps f6 initiates
this right through threatening to
prepare you you you you can win the
bishop on b7 but that was wrong yeah f6
trust it down so okay well they're all I
mean yeah I was surprised by Bishop g6
practically speaking would would would
either of you have captured that night
on g6 I mean it's worth thinking about
only if you can ensconce your knight on
an advance like d6 if I gave my knight
on these six I'll do it right I know
it's gonna sit there
the only thing is I would need a pawn
guarding it because my queen wants to
roam it doesn't want to be the one
guarding this night just because it gets
on d6 doesn't mean anything but if I
could get let's say what was the
position he played well the bishop was
on d3 like if you made some move mmm
what do you need to do you make this
move
G yeah and you give me this move yeah
and you play this move and I play that
move right and I know I get this
position yeah no I'll do it
laughs initely trade let's go for it
definitely would trade so that would
mean I'd have to have the pawn on e5
before I traded and then play Knight in
right so yeah so what the bottom line is
you would not have given up the bishop
unless you could have had a definitive
way to establishing your knight on the
exam and in advance out so for example
if you were here and you make a waiting
known I would have played f6 right of
course you would but let's say you make
a move like this I do this and you know
waste a little wasted time now this
capture appeals because you can assure
the knight on this square that's and and
now I mean it's not winning right wait
wait actually this might be winning
already rot row yeah someone like this
and here goes upon off the board showing
the flexibility of the night so that's
already where we're doing something I
feel like it's still still probably a
draw right this is where I would do it
I knew my knight had a future but if the
knight has no specific future like as
how he played in the game bishops HD 6
HD 6 and E 4 looking for the next two
moves and now Queen c7 is indeed on the
board Queen c7 was played and that
formation that he's after with E 5 and
then Knight d6 looks virtually
impossible right now I mean II 5 in this
position already is begging a lot of
questions and one Queen c5 check what do
you do now King oh ok let's go let's go
here for the moment and any Bishop move
Bishop a six-night d6 back - is this
back to that endgame you talked about
your back this one yeah yeah although
somehow the knight undie 6 got
established right but what's it gonna do
yeah I'm not sure I I don't think black
is unhappy thanks to the split Queen
side pawns yeah exactly
so here we go Queen c7 I start I started
flash before yeah it is on the board
let's see another source yes Queen c7 is
indeed on the board and Magnus looks
like you can make a drawer with Queen d2
you'll have to evaluate the position I
think it's only tries e5 only real
trying that's my opinion only thing to
do now is e5 in and say I might have
something in that position what else do
you see he could possibly do here no no
ii 5 is definitely when he played Bishop
takes g6 this is what he was going for
an idea where he would get an advanced
outpost for his knight such as the d6
squared this is but is he risking I'm
not a hundred percent sure night versus
Bishop with pawns on both flanks usually
that's supposed to favor the bishop and
it does he's plated 'if I was on the
board he has not played the move Queen
d2 he does not see himself as being any
worse yes and that's where where we're
looking at it because it
definitely is quite feasible for black
to go for this bishop a six line and
allow the fractured pawn structure but
is that really good for white or or is
that really good for black optically to
us it looks like you're compromising
your structure from what was an even
balance completely balanced structure we
already now have the imbalance number
one district versus Knight and
potentially imbalance number two pawn
structure on the Queen side this
position again
the engines are saying well we can look
at it and say this looks fairly even the
angels are saying definitely even black
cannot undermine the night with f6
because of the move f4 and you cannot
attack any of the dark square buttons
right yeah why can't get his King
through in any way there's no break
fruit for the King no you mean black
can't well why it was all what I was
saying black it could theoretically it
doesn't doesn't black well yeah
theoretically but King d7 c6 King d5 I
mean
oh you mean play or anything like leave
you moves for a second if we don't mind
so we get something like this yeah the
King would go up the king would go over
so on a very good day I mean I realized
that I have 98 yes so I just stick my
king on D far side I mean to remind
white that g2 is weak we already know g7
as we well it's an interesting imbalance
position I I would not have thought that
white is to be preferred though but
couldn't I also just swivel my night
from efore to d6 or something like that
oh no once I get to that position okay
sorry once you once you run with your
King I can just play like 94 94 now and
just probably provoked me to retreat
yeah hang back yeah okay well yeah it's
a drum right it's a draw
it's a draw but it's it's more
interesting than the other draws though
yeah exactly cuz we get to see these
pieces
the night in the bishop faith off well I
mean this was the moment when Magnus
felt look if I have anything at all I
have to create some kind of imbalances
some create some tension and at least
this has created this Bishop versus
night and balance and now this
intriguing but nobody basics yet right
they split pause because we throw in the
queen a queen c5 check to hurt the king
before he goes all right yeah maybe
queen c5 king h2 just a chase the kid
why not yeah okay that makes perfect
sense to me I think that just loses you
a tempo from the gate legs we were just
talking about right well the King's
gonna know what King is not happy to be
on h2 it was better it was happier when
it was centralized a moment ago but how
big of a difference does that make in
that line let's just take a look at how
bad it is I have no idea
yeah fade or yeah King of fate will
start questions maybe if I should use a
different route now like eight know you
still think G ones probably the best
route well you can go G for King G yeah
let me just try the the original route
kim jiwon okay snap for me seven King up
to so yeah it does feel like black has
gained a tempo but they advance to the
queen c5 check to what end
question is what sorry I mean because we
still have this 98 thing yeah I mean of
the meaningful is i gaining a tempo was
a good idea you know I think it's in
there exactly give me the tempo
alright seriously
suppose I thought you know I'm the
greatest player in the world I have to
win every game I play suppose I play g5
what say you all is this King III King
III and let's say King d7 so I want to
play Bishop f1 I really do but I'm
afraid that this Knight see a check is
an
so I I'm guarding the CH never I could
take on G Farben I can sir
oh you could you you want triplets I did
it okay
tonight I seven night s7 so now you've
got a triplet Wow okay I haven't fully
well I didn't analyze it all their
interpretation it's probably a kind of
like right like the good news we wanted
anyway so that's not the point
so now I'm trying now we just got fun
actually Eric Rosen tweeting for us
chess just showed this essay evaluations
and the funny thing is you know a lot of
times we joke you know triple zeros
right but that triple zero is like one
line and they hacked fine and if you
mess it up and then you might not get
that draw right here are showing the top
50 moves are triple ha ha 50 moves for
black or triple zero that goes to show
how really really really balanced basic
c6 King Essex King h7 King h8 are all
triple zero moves yeah f6 g5 Queenie a
queen e7 Queen c5 check oh wait the
Queen c5 is the only one that didn't
make it oh this sorry this was last move
okay yeah so that's really this was a
seven yeah that that goes to show out
how extraordinarily even we were found
one you found one that was like a little
juicy
well that's our job we got a create
chaos
why'd you give up on the position we
were looking at oh I don't know I I
thought that you would want to take the
moves back up what I thought you're
ready to admit that you stood badly why
do you think dude you're not ready day I
was trying to find my wedding plan when
you
so I I was trying to be sportive on your
behalf and we've got some position like
this the game went back to g1 here year
and I was G fire now you play g5 first
oh I beg your pardon I did and then you
went King III then I went King d7 and
then you you accepted the triplets which
I thought was dubious that you want a
pawn I went here
you took the pawn now here I went king
b5 and you said then you got yourself
all excited and I said alright King d5
alright King it for king f4 and let me
get my Bishop finally downstairs so I
wanna play B five and I win my pawn back
one day but it may take me a while to
win my pawn back yeah I ain't never seen
that one haha Knight I have several G's
you see tries but hold on I need to get
to that squared that you do that I do Oh
g6 just for fun g7 g6 just for fun okay
looks good
queasy v check has been played Queen c5
check oh yes so they're gonna follow
this exact analysis we're gonna see this
position exact twelve-month but anyway
so you took right I'd okay now I'm
pulling Knight g4 Nigerian I can sense
there's a for coming up in the position
king h2 so they are following our
analysis of course they are right now
but dude I've got a passport and you
don't you know yes sir I want to win
that pawn of yours in a second you you
already won one of the e pawns you can't
get them both I mean one e pawn per game
that's that's the new rule guys okay
you could only sacrifice your people Oh
might I want to play Knight f6 right now
but your ePHI move makes me look stupid
Knight f6
oh I'll fall for it
I won't play e5 ever well promise you
won't get away without one but it was a
nice shot and nice try
okay so this this trick I was looking
for doesn't work let's back up a couple
of moves and I won't give you this pawn
yet so I'm gonna play what you do oh I
play King f king GD v King in for Bishop
up one night G for let's play more reach
than IG for mmm-hmm in the same business
right yeah right still got his I still
got to go back right at least you could
maybe keep your extra pawn
and your King has kept off the game you
know pretty well then I'm going back to
that little tricky idea by the way but I
just want you to stay back I was just
curious way back here and the move I was
inclined to play I didn't you you you
scared me out of it you bluffed me it
was a bluff it was the block but it's a
dynamic bluff at least so let's go with
g6g say wait should I just go for the
pawn directly and maybe get some other
options as well howdy
mmm Knight d7 Oh 97 night here well okay
what would you like
please I'm gonna put I wanna play a 97
alrighty fair enough and I was going I
was going directly for this pawn
obviously so you saw me even if I win
you're a pawn it doesn't matter it's all
by Knight f6 Knight f6 I was gonna take
the pawn yeah and then Knight age 5 or
in Knight age 498 okay so these are the
positions where as a kid I was always
taught that the bishop was superior
because it could cover the that the
promoting square right so you're gonna
go to c4 so something like this this
this and I don't know this and then this
right so I've got a pass ball you've got
a pass palm but my bishop when I go
EEE five covers the palm yeah you might
have made me blunder there though I
probably did because I could play
because I complain after I took the pawn
okay we were back here
you did what I went here you went here I
went here I could play Knight eight
Knight e8 okay Knight d6 no no you're
right because the efficiency six well
this is this is the power of the bishop
over the night it can it can cover from
afar a promoting Paul's gonna happen
okay but okay the current position let
me sorry I'm just after Queen c7 we had
45 check g5 via Queen c5 check King H 2
and alpha v 2 think happy thinking
because he does have bishop that was ago
when you played the move Queen c7
hitting G 3 4 0 0 0
oh my word so even a move like f6 that
would be a 5th Essex is one of them King
moves are one of them like every lots of
Queen moves out to Bishop right I even
hardly any which was basics was played
by the way well it's the most human move
but uh even when Sesay mentioned that
Bishop a8 was 0 0 I would not have
thought of Bishop a well yeah of course
you're not gonna play that did that very
different story that just didn't come
into my consciousness question yes move
30 it is its move 30 yet does black one
does black or for a drum Bishop a z96
played oh alright so if you didn't offer
strong forget it
or if you did or didn't it doesn't
matter because the night is is now on d6
and the game continues well it seems to
mean like both players were anxious to
embrace
position obviously when Magnus played
the move Bishop takes g6 he had saw a
variation like the game consist we're
talking about that night being a short
of the d6 squared right
but with Queens on Queens off with the
bad pawn structure mmm
you know what though if again as as
white we made some moves I was trying to
beat you in that position sure why it
doesn't have any losing chances here not
real ones not with the knight on d6
because in chances he doesn't have only
one white driver working hard if white
doesn't try white doesn't lose oh I
think you're saying if white doesn't try
why just sits there how do you make any
progress in this position that's black I
think that's the critical question
because I see because he can trade off
things as you as they arise right right
and and what what are you gonna prove
what what is your winning plan procedure
if white doesn't go crazy and play some
you know nutty things on the understood
well the only thing I had was that that
that that King walking to a four okay by
that with an I don't we trades we do
have Queen Giants that's not Queen takes
c3 B takes c3 I'm expecting King f8
right so the it's pretty much what we've
said it's gonna be a pawn on f4 is going
to be a king coming into the middle both
Kings are gonna come toward the middle
of the board and the night is on d6 what
is your path to this a Foursquare
if your as a night sitting on d6 what is
your kings path that he's going to e7 to
d7 to c6 to D to c5 and you're just
going to keep the night there forever so
that my king can't cross to the b5 now
what you could do what you could try to
do is you could try to take my EEP on oh
wait but you got to worry about night on
1998 so okay again I said so okay just
so let's make some more F for King e7
right can G 1 which is our our analysis
right yeah absolutely so I have to play
f6 to release my king my king is playing
nursemaid
- this pawn on f7 so that's why I played
f6 now I'm a little bit worried that if
my King John's too far there's gonna be
a 98 that was a lot worried g5 right
okay so here I've tried to do our King
III King III was fine and here is where
I went King here okay I wanna play King
back to have to yes
okay now you're just basically saying
I'm not gonna do anything
show me what you can do - right what's
your the actual board position on the
right okay so to have six husband played
we okay so they are getting closer and
closer to our our course of action so
I'm not that thrilled about my bishop
being on this diagonal let me see if I
can't find a better diagonal how about
bishop here Maurice can you three I'm
just gonna wait for you to show your
plan okay I'll put my bishop back maybe
on g6 that stops any Knight e8 madness
from happening King F - mm-hmm okay now
that I don't have to worry about your
knight penetrating okay okay so I've got
essentially you've given me the max I'm
just certain yeah I want to see what
your plan is okay but can I do this
though man
this is what you this is the one thing
you've got to avoid right is allowing my
king to cozy up to the e5 pawn so you
got a lot but I didn't do it no no I'm
still not avoiding that you just get all
that what happens when i - c c8 here
because your night your you stop me from
your jeep oh he didn't summon me April
ooh but your Knight gets trapped right
are you sure you want to do this this is
this is where you could get scared I
would get scared that the night is
getting trapped by the bishop yeah
there's some stuff to be afraid of it is
possible to to lose a position like this
one but it takes some effort is what
you're saying
you got to be creative it's not so easy
for white to lose even if he doesn't
everyone up to try to do anything right
that's that's where I want to see
intriguing very intriguing what's your
take Jennifer draw a percentage too high
that even even with best efforts the
players can't avoid the draw oh yeah I I
agree with that what you could say
finding the best paths with the under
far more pressure with far more ways to
mess up right with far fewer options to
save the day but it's funny how Annan
said in his interview that sometimes the
moves in that game one game Magnus just
floored everyone with his brilliance in
the first link 35 moves yeah that was
phenomenal and so it was ironic to vichy
that well he found all these difficult
moves and then the easy moves that you
know we all saw right instantly not
reading him and other elite grandmaster
right that they magnus miss those yeah
well the things he was mentioning is
that Magnus has this extraordinary
ability to get positions I'll play his
opponent and give himself winning
chances now back in 2013-2014 Magnus was
then taking those winning positions in
converting them and the point that Vichy
was making in his interview is of late
you can say the last two years Magnus
even though he's been getting those
chances he hasn't been converting them
just like he was doing in 20 2013 and
one of my other favorite things about
the interview was how Anand was saying
to the contrary yes like it's completely
illogical that Magnus would avoid the
most sharp lines
and it's almost like a little bit of a
poker game he knows that if he knows
that once you play these sharp lines and
allow me to go into it it means that you
know way better than I do right so I
better just take the safe route and
right she says like hey ego aside that's
a smart choice right that he's just
saying let's be very very practical I
don't even want to take the risk that
you have prepared the position so well
and so deeply I don't want to play
against your 3,600 engine and and that
begs the question at some point somebody
could just do that like for instance you
can even just to give you a small
example like suppose Magnus plays
allowing a hobby to go for the open
Sicilian but he actually hasn't really
studied the open Sicilian as much as
mother thinks he has that could come up
in a situation that that's like a brutal
brutal brutal Bluff I remember in the
world team championship in Ningbo China
it was the US vs Israel and I was
playing against Ilyas Marin and we had
this incredible super sharp choral
composition on the board and Ilya
sacrificed upon and then every fiber of
my being wanted to capture that pawn but
I went through the same gyrations that
Magnus was going through fearing my
opponent's preparation I shied away and
I didn't take the pawn and the game was
eventually drawn regret it to this day
you know after the game post-mortem my
ass Ilya
well well sorry you know but what was
your what was your prep he said sorry I
made a finger failure the moral of the
story is you should always take the pawn
is that right I don't know what the
moral I know sorry but I but but the
thing is is because of the super because
the computers are playing such a key
role at so much of our preparation and
sometimes you just blunder you make a
finger failure well but you're not
punished for it because everybody thinks
ooh
profound what a deep deep preparation my
opponent has played I better avoid the
obvious win hey I mean it imagine this
caliber we can assume that there's not a
lot of bluffing that they have prepared
all the lines but think about how for
people watching at home think about how
you could use this yourself that
sometimes and a lot of people find out
this the hard way and it's almost a bit
frustrating because they're trying a new
line of the Sicilian and they're you
know they're working on all the lines
but they haven't got it at all super
super tight right I have you know the
knight or if the dragon to get it super
tight especially the first few months of
playing it even if you're a super GM but
then when they start playing it in their
Club tournaments everybody's playing to
see three Sicilian or the Bishop b5
avoid your open Sicilian okay there's a
lot of great lines against those moves
that are imbalanced and punishing for
black so it is kind of it's not an
intended Bluff but it often works out in
that way well I remember when MBL was
really getting this great great
reputation a deserved reputation as a
knight or player and everybody was
avoiding the open knight or against him
it was like really really frustrated
because nobody would give him the
position he wanted although I feel like
you could go either way because it's
also it's also technically probably the
open Sicilian at the most testing choice
right absolutely so when as long as you
as we saw with Magnus not having a lot
of problems in the Rhossili MO and then
the c3 Sicilian there's good line so
close Sicilian there's good line so I
think you could look at it either way I
guess it just depends how much you want
to play those slash-and-burn opposite
side castle Sicilian exactly well this
could have been one of those
slash-and-burn opposite side castling
positions but it's not it not only isn't
it but I really got the sense that that
that there was no way that Magnus was
going to allow such a double edged game
could you bring me up to date on the
moves that have been played after the
Queen trade we did see f7 f6 did we see
f4 we did okay
a very dramatic f4 and King f8 well so
far yeah I think our analysis had
continued King g1 King e7 King F - but
those moves have not yet to be played
right and if I could ask you what the
times of the two planners even though
it's not accurate just give me a
approximation it looks like we're at
about twenty five to eight for Fabi so
small disadvantage for Fabi but with
five moves until the next time 25
minutes for Magnus to move 40 and what
did you say please 8 8 no no not with
only 5 moves to make in the time control
right yeah exactly and then they'll get
their second bonus exactly ok as we were
mentioning all right let us I was gonna
say let us take a break and let us share
with our audience we've got we've been
doing some very very nice fireside chats
as Maurice Jennifer and I were talking
about the World Championship history
that's right and there's some been some
brilliant epochs of great great great
players and I think we're up to
Karpov Korchnoi that's right Wow amazing
what a rivalry what an intense intense
rivalry that was that was so much fun
sit back and enjoy exactly now for drama
political intrigue and simple craziness
manic yeah we gotta talk about the
matches between Karpov and Korchnoi and
there was three of them and it were
three of them now the first one was an
official world champion for the World
Championship because it was the finals
of the Candice's who would play Bobby
Fischer but then Fischer decide
it's not he doesn't like the terms in
1975 fides not listening to what he
likes and he says that's it I'm out up
until the last day right and he says I'm
out and Karpov is crowned the world
champion because he's defeated Korchnoi
three-to-two means I have many draws 25
years a little bit of the shoulder right
he's thinking I didn't really beat the
guy right so he has to prove himself and
he has to prove himself time and time
again who does he have to prove himself
against it's the same guy over and over
the courts no Victor the Terrible keeps
coming back again and again
right so Victor quarter no defects from
the Soviet Union and he becomes the
Challenger officially in 1978 and 1981
and for the whole world championship
cycle of 1980 1981 I was one of the
seconds along with Michael steam loved
Goodman and I got a chance to work with
Victor for weeks and weeks and months
and months and I'm talking 12 14 hour
days so I get to know the Viktor
Korchnoi and he was a very mixed
personality a man of really strong great
passions this is a guy he would convince
you that he's going to bring that
mountain ten feet closer to his home and
he's gonna do it with the shovel he's
gonna do it every day every day and he
is determined to make that mountain move
well for what I remember just amazing
his his father I believe died in a
bombing when he was 10 years old again
World War 2 in World War two so let me
he had he gone an Obama siege of
leningrad and he had to go through all
this deprivation to refer to jellify be
who he is to survive to survive and he
was known as a guy who if you gave him a
pawn he'd be like thanks for the pawn
I'm walking through the Gobi Desert I'll
do whatever it takes you ain't getting
it because he was such a tremendous
fender and such a steely personality
really very very much so and in 1974
that match that he played with Karpov
the finals to determine who was going to
play Bobby Fischer had huge political
overtones in the Soviet Union because
keep in mind there's the Soviet Chess
Federation man but there's the Russian
sports committee in anything sports goes
underneath the Russian sports company
and it was a Russian sports committee
who told the Chess Federation what's
their policy going to be and their
policy was they wanted to support the
younger Karpov they thought that that
guy had a better chance against Fischer
then did Korchnoi so all the Soviets
were supporting Anatoly Karpov and
Corson told me lots of stories I can't
bore you all with the stories but
they're fine they're fine so a lot of
the grandmasters the soviet grandmasters
could not work with coronally either
officially or in public or anything and
it was all surreptitious you know you go
to the phone booth six corners away and
then you call it eleven and we'll tell
you our analysis kind of thing I mean
it's all cloak-and-dagger did they have
to sign some paperwork also some of them
signed paperwork against coordinating he
decided that he was going to defect that
was there any people Jenner that's right
I remember
Karpov didn't sign I believe Petrossian
didn't sign a couple of others in Simon
but but they had to say that's right
this guy persona non-grata to us that's
right because he decided he had to and
he left behind his wife and yeah Bella
yeah
Bella and Igor so okay so the point is
it goes efore ecigs d4 d5 it's a French
now Korchnoi is playing the French
defense against Anatoly Karpov in car
buffs playing the tirage was 92 so Roman
gingy Hodge Philly who couldn't be his
official second right is been working on
the move Bishop f8 to e7 on move three
it's a special special move right
and then Victor gets into a telephone
conversation with David Bronstein okay
top guy and he's on the phone and he and
David says I've got a move for you on
move three a bishop move for you to play
against Karpov and I've worked it all
out and he goes yeah yeah I know it's
Bishop e7 and gingi told me
no it's Bishop d7 Bishop c8 to d7 on
move three against the terrace and you
can go into the Fort Knox variation so
it's hilarious that there's gorge door
juggling two top grandmasters that he
can't meet with them in public because
of the Soviet Union and then the match
continues with this kind of intrigue
throughout throughout the snow that they
happen in this manner yogurt gate
because that comes later yeah in the
later matches right where you get will
you get these you can't bring the yogurt
to the table because there might be a
code depending on which color yogurt was
correct send a parapsychologist that's
right where the they're using their
minds to influence the way you're
thinking right and guys can't sit in the
front of row because you guys are
psychologists who are intimidating them
with with their minds I mean I was a
wild stuff exactly but even before we
get into the 78 match though we got the
75 match to deal with so so there's
Fischer list of demands I'm gonna play
this young punk kid Anatoly Karpov
Ferdinand Marcos says let's cut the crap
here's five million dollars now keep in
mind that Bobby Fischer played Boris
Spassky how much chordoma correct five
million dollars I don't want to hear
about some rules and what's gonna happen
and then the five million dollars get
your butt over here to play I think even
Carlson and Caruana would play four five
in today's dollars versus those dollars
seventy five so it's amazing to chess
fans myself especially included
I say that how Bobby turned that down
that was just for the straight 24-game
which became the standard after world
war two you played 24 games he Bobby
wanted to play like steinitz the first
10 victories wins the match caught by 9
keeping the title for the champ that's
right he disagreed suit that's right
so they went to the first to win 6 they
changed the rules as a compromise Bobby
said I ain't playing Muhammad Ali and
George Foreman they're thriller and
Manila
Bobby Fischer didn't come and pick up
the paycheck Muhammad Ali and George
Frazier did that was what that money
came from George no George Frazier
Frazier Ali Joe Frazier Joe Frazier
sorry yeah
Joe Frazier that was where that money
came from was from the chess match 1978
Manila was wild that's where you get
your parapsychologist that's where you
this is Baguio City all right Bobby oh
yeah that's where Anatoly Karpov man you
know like some servant would come and
bring them a tea or a coffee
fair enough here's a tea or coffee but
on our number one he get a yogurt but
what kind of a yogurt if it's a
blueberry yogurt maybe that's a thing
that you should be moving your knife if
it's raspberry you know what raspberry
sounds like Bishop berries bishop
raspberries rook cetera it was some wild
stuff yeah went on you know we really
should give karpova's do I know you were
playing on Korchnoi steam you were 1981
Korchnoi but Karpov does win both
matches they're incredible fights that
just struggles beyond belief epic stuff
that his people should really be looking
at but Karpov does win both and he goes
on to prove him sober the next 10 years
that he's really the true champion
that's cuz he's got the chip on his
shoulder that Bobby Fischer never
knocked off because he won the match by
forfeit and every game he plays he comes
with the attitude I've got to prove
myself gotta prove that I'm the real
world champion and in those 10 years he
was phenomena
he was a dominant world champion go look
at that go look at that tournament
record until we meet one youngster that
is to come but certainly epic those two
double K matches one of many that will
happen between Karpov and Korchnoi yes
certainly a storybook time in chess
World Championship history absolutely
hello and welcome back to today in chess
world championship edition as we are
gonna update you on the game the game 7
of Carlsen Cara wanna which does not
seem like it's the trend breaker in
terms of these six drawers that we've
had so far yes this is a position right
now as we see kuranes King has crawled
to d7 right when we left it we had seen
it around these the this moment we had
expected f6 and f4 and all of these
moves really have not surprises in the
least
I had actually in some analysis with
Maurice a little pitter-patter ayah
tossed in g5 but these are this is well
within our expectation and I do believe
that we're heading for our seventh
consecutive draw nothing much I can say
about the position it's just so well
balanced another another well played
game or this one day well played
I mean the sense of 5 & 6 where these
were like epically well played draws
this one you can see players of lesser
stature playing the similar game right
now I just felt that you know there are
certain things in chess that are I find
very very challenging and sometimes a
player has their favorite defense a
groom fell defense and I do everything
in my power to avoid your grünfeld
defense I'm playing all of these other
variations and sometimes I just feel
like you just have to challenge and test
your opponent whether it be in an open
Sicilian as you have ventured already or
in this case something like a castles or
Bishop g5 and I just felt that in all of
the cases where Magnus has been white he
has not taken the game to a B and as a
result Abi's actually had a pretty easy
go of it with the black pieces that's
the bottom line is the way I feel it and
in this particular gaze what I'm really
talking about is the move Bishop e2 in
today's game
as I think that there were other much
more important challenging moves that
should have been tried we'll see how you
get tried okay but there are me as a
species plant which I kind of sympathize
with because a visi like me it really
makes a lot of logical sense he's then
the flaw that Magnus hadn't considered
Queen d8 so he was out of his prep I
mean ideally he's in his prep against
Bobby yeah but okay so queen d8 could be
in a semi surprise as much right
followed by Bishop c5 b6 also being a
little bit of a surprise but it's not
but first of all there are a lot of
trans positions right a lot of not after
Bishop d6 yeah but you you can get a lot
of trans positions but also you learn a
lot about the middle games and you
understand if I'm cancelling long how am
I being tested I capture on d5 and my
King gets skewered on the C file got it
I Castle long and I get to go g4 g5
faster than you're ready to be able to
meet it so I'm saying you already have a
familiarity with what type of positions
what type of tactics or strategy
strategical challenges await you and
Magnus basically said well I'm not ready
for it yet well I think in that case I
go back to move one where I feel that it
seems like over the three moves the one
that he's gotten the most out of is one
c4 he has the English opening that was
the one game and we spoke about it
earlier where it just felt like white
had an edge out of the opening he kept
it for a very very very long time it
never really flowered in anything
significant but that was the only game
that white really was dictating
but-but-but-but-but solid raw but no no
no no again information advantage as
vichy said you saw that you got an inch
he saw that you got an edge and if it's
that serious then he would have
revisited that position if it was all
clear that like this is where I should
be because you're not well prepared
enough or because I'm going to get an
advantage then he would be back in c4
yeah
imagine that he's gonna say well you
know what I mean let me save c4 so you
can prepare it a couple more days
another three days no he would have gone
right back there so it's not it was not
clear enough to him and his team that
this was a real problem for for black
and that's and that must be why he's
avoided it for now I think you're
totally right Maurice because if you
think about it from fabi's point of view
Fabi could have just simply tried to
play the the same lines against Steve
work at c4 Fabi was the one to choose to
play e5 he's not forced to play repeats
e4 e5 you could go east six and d5 like
a Queens gambit exactly in which case
Magnus just allows him more options by
playing by playing c4 so actually it's
not easy at all for him right now you
didn't get anything against the petrov
he's not getting anything about this
he's got a real challenge but i guess he
doesn't have that many whites that's a
couple of moves to discuss King III
Bishop f1 on the board and then King
back to f2 okay's the board position and
now we expect the bishop to head back I
would say he's probably say to d3 normal
to just back let's see d3 makes sense
but Bishop a6 I believe was played all
traces on the board and we could see a
repetition right now with King to e3
Bishop f1 that'll be one way for them to
get there and then the game would be
drawn by the way we should point out
we're gonna have a special guest
tomorrow yes championship challenger of
2004 wow this is we don't get the
Switzerland
really regretted I didn't make that net
match that was it that was a great match
yes and Peter like oh another incredibly
speaking player who's never yet played
in the st. Louis chess club but he's
joining us on the air tomorrow that's
November 19th that's gonna be Perowne
date there appear from him so we're just
on the verge of calling Game seven a
draw as they've gone back and forth a
couple of times have they Maurice how
many times is that
the ship is entered to f1 twice so far
twice it's the second time the Bishop
has landed in that form okay so we've
seen King d7 King III Bishop f1 once the
bishop went all the way back to a6 and
King III and the Bishop went all the way
down so this is a twice that we have on
our board you know what this means yes
now the score is gonna be three and a
half three and a half and that means
that we're guaranteed to have chess on
Thanksgiving because right it's the
first to score six and a half points so
it's impossible for this game match and
before around hand and I mean I think in
you know all probably 95% of the chances
it's gonna go the whole 12 exactly very
unlikely for anything else to happen at
this point right so we're in for it
we're in for a ride and well I'm looking
forward to Thanksgiving yeah yeah
Thanksgiving just a turkey
let's talk please let's just talk game 8
because we mentioned before four out of
the seven matches so far just maybe it's
just pure coincidence but four of them
that the the 712 game matches that have
been played in history and it's only
recent history four of those have ended
decisively at game eight and Caruana
will have the white pieces we'll be able
to make something finally with white
with the serve is it that critical and
somebody's gonna have to break this tie
if not then they will tie a record I'm
not sure it's a record you want to
embrace but they will tie a record for
eight straight draws to begin a match
first done and it is a draw now so they
have tied for second place seven
straight games as did Mac as the Magnus
and Kuryakin the last match two years
ago they have now tied that seven games
in a row to start a match with a draw
and these players are looking very even
and I have to say today advantage Fabi
Bobby took two blacks in a row one he
had a forced win on the board
okay esoteric but at least he
show that black was fine and then he had
another black today and it was even
easier today if you can say that he just
made a few moves and suddenly Magnus
back down from all the issues and he
made a draw so remember we're talking
about him walking the gauntlet he could
have scored one and a half half from
walking this gauntlet with the black
pieces again does white have anything at
all or lack of anything to worry about
when facing the white pieces as Bobby
played two blocks in a row against
Magnus and Magnus did not win again
nineteen games in the World Championship
Magnus is only one one of his last two
World Championships only one game you
took a back when you stated and he he
said to you well when you put it like
that that's not really domination is it
also given that he lost like three games
to Magnus in each of the matches Rob
they played so look at you're getting
like twenty thirteen match right you are
under not usually I'm a hundred percent
on team fella beat but let me just give
you the other argument about what Anton
said in a way you could say Magnus did
it the best way possible because you
wouldn't buy the minimum meaning that
when you're in the most efficient yes
exact way possible so I think there's
like another way to look at it what does
that mean what what explain that you're
trying to be as efficient as possible
you win I won you win you win and then
you're glide of course that's not
actually hours been where I can get
where where's the win what are you
talking about so what are you talking
about the car yeah could match he lost
and and then had to win and then had to
lay a tie-break I went to the maximum
all four games so that was not a minimal
of strategy he thought he was a favorite
of the tiebreaks and that's why he drew
the last game with white relatively
quickly yes but he was down in the match
let's let's be real he was on the heavy
pressure and could have even lost was it
there was there's another game that was
not dominant match I'm gonna agree with
that I'm just saying that there's
something to be said for the fact they
need to match it's kind of like in a
match if if you're you're just trying to
win you don't get a bonus really for
winning by three
no you don't are you trying to win the
match but you do get a bonus by winning
by two because then you don't have to
worry about last game right right well
likely at this day you know any victory
and I just wanted to because you'd
mentioned something Maurice you were
about to give us your final thoughts
there but it was really this position I
thought that this was the key moment in
today's game was after 93
fabbi did something very very unusual in
the hundreds or so game that this was as
these types of position didn't played
it's automatic no grandmasters really
have thought about it before they've all
universally retreated their Bishop to e7
a completely different approach by
Fabiana he played the move Bishop b6
very very unexpected and he went Queen
e7 and d4 pardon me he went Queen e7
looking to play d4 and I thought this
was the key moment in today's game and
there was three really challenging moves
Bishop g5 rook d1 as well as castles
long and when I saw Magnus play the move
Bishop e2 same response is the last time
when he saw a novelty in this opening
exactly he just shut the game down and
he said I'm not taking any risk I'm
gonna play the most practical and then
we had Vichy on and this she was
explaining why Magnus takes the approach
he does and this is what has led to
today's match where White has come up
empty-handed
in so many of these games no advantages
I'll point out that Fabiana was asked a
question in a press conference about
whether or not chess is dying as a
result of engines and preparation in
preparation and he said that actually he
thinks it's actually becoming more rich
he said by looking at these ideas so
deeply there's so many discoveries that
they're making as keeping the game
interesting now this one you might say
well this game was not that interesting
but the fact that he could play
move that every grandmaster and his
sister plays Bishop e7 and he decided
Bishop b7 a bishop b6 excuse me is the
right move is another move right in this
relation then that shows that the game
is much broader than we suppose if in
fact this line is great as well but
speaking of sisters the sister geum's
will come in tomorrow and start their
World Championship match as it has been
epic fights draws what's wrong and it's
saying blood have knock-down drag-out
amazing fights in the Women's World
Championship match and we will see it
again starting tomorrow as jus engine
woman's world champion that is from
China will take on the Russian and
Katerina like no in the finals they have
a four-game match to start before they
start their tie breaks if it ever gets
to that and man the way these ladies
have played Jew engine with Ally
headlock on everybody she's played so
far playing the minimum number of games
only 10 games so far again scattering
like no who's that to fight thrashing
working so hard to get to their finals
playing 21 games more than double that
the her Challenger or a competitor will
I had played so far so this is going to
be epic I'm looking forward to seeing
what they produce in their battles
as it it simply has been so rich whoever
wins is fully deserving off the title
and I think everyone will be satisfied
and saying yes this woman is the new
women's world champion because they have
shown their fighting spirit throughout
this tournament their excellence
absolutely deserved and it should be a
great match
- great finalists no question about that
I'm looking forward to that match as
well Jennifer you get the final word
well I'm just thrilled to see the
tension keep building in Carlson Cara
Juana as we were so gratified to have
five-time world champion
Vijay Anand join us today join us
tomorrow for more special guests
including
Peter Lecco and of course I'll be with
grandmasters Yasir Sarah Ron and Maurice
Ashley to bring you all the action
starting at 9 a.m. central that's
tomorrow Monday and that's 10 o'clock in
the east coast thank you for joining us
I have a great day we'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]